if you're not where you want to be is
you got to feed and strengthen your mind
but Jim ran was my original teacher and
he used to have this simple practice he
used to say Tony every day you got to
stand guard at the door of your mind he
asked me a question I remember early on
I was 17 years old your worst enemy puts
sugar in your coffee what's going to
happen I said you going to have sweet
coffee he goes what if your best friend
or your parent or your Your Lover by
accident drops one drop of strict nine
in your coffee what's going to happen
you'd be dead he goes That's Right life
is both sugar and strick N so you better
watch your coffee stand guard at the
door of your mind and the way used to
say that is every day take 30 minutes of
your day and read not that comes to you
today not the clickbait where you pick
up a book and you read something that
has philosophy or psychology or skill
where you are immersing yourself for 30
minutes in improving who you are he said
because if you do that every single day
it'll accumulate over the decades until
you'll be at a point where you won't
even believe all that you've experienced
in live hey it's EV car Michael and I
make these videos because I need them
because being around successful
entrepreneurs who are pushing who are
driving who are doing amazing things
things gives me that extra little
motivational inspirational boost in the
morning every day to help me go off and
accomplish great things too and I hope
that this video gives you that
inspiration as well so today let's get
some incredible motivation from the one
and only Tony Robins
[Music]
enjoy I think the most important Habit
to start with is having something that
you care about more than yourself a
mission it could be your family it could
be photography it could be your business
it could be you know something you want
to do in your community it could be
Humanity but I don't mean virtue
signaling I mean you know what you're
really driven by and when people have
something that they care about more than
themselves they don't run out of energy
they don't run out of excitement because
you know if it's just about you it's
easy to get comfortable and comfort
makes you not grow you people ask me all
the time Tony you meet millions of
people what's the secret to happiness
and I always laugh and say it's pretty
simple it's one word progress progress
equals happiness because if you're not
making progress you're not growing and
there's only a few rules in the universe
they're not mine they're the universe
everything grows or dies and everything
contributes Beyond itself or it's
eventually eliminated by Evolution and
so you know for me growing and giving is
the game and so you got to find
something that makes you want to keep
growing and giving so you don't get
comfortable you can't sit at the table
of success too long or you get fat and
bored right so we need to feel alive we
and you know a lot of people achieve a
goal and then their brain goes is this
all there is
or even if you achieved a goal you loved
you know it's like you loved it how long
did you stay excited about whatever you
succeeded at you know you may have
worked on it for years did you say
excited for a year almost never you know
nine months 6 months three months three
weeks three days three hours because
you're not supposed to stay just
satisfied because our nature is to grow
and when we grow we have something to
give so to me that's the core people get
vested in their trauma people get vested
in their pain if you want to know the
largest drug on the planet it's not
cocaine it's not heroin uh it's not pot
it's not you know some prescription drug
the biggest you know drug on the planet
is problems because everyone has a deep
fear everyone and the deepest fears we
have are two one is that we're not
enough we're not smart enough young
enough Rich enough pretty enough funny
enough something enough and if we're not
enough it DS the deepest fear we have
which is we won't be loved and love is
the ox the soul so you know a baby is if
they're not physically kinesthetically
loved they develop what's called failure
to thrive syndrome that's how desperate
our nervous system is for love so human
beings when they think oh my God if I
fail at this it'll look like I'm not
enough and I won't be worthy of Love
they tend to come up with a reason why
that's either not their fault it's
something that was done to me I've got
ADHD I was born with it I was raped I
was whatever and they might even tell
the truth someone may have really raped
it's a horrible situation but other
people raped and they've gotten through
it and they're on the other side of it
this person hasn't because it becomes
their reason for not being where they
want to be in their life and so the
bottom line is a mother can lose her
daughter or son through a drunk driver
and spend the rest of their life in pain
and another one creates mad Mothers
Against Drunk drivers and does something
about it and feels a sense of freedom
and a sense of serving that child and a
sense of higher purpose than what
they're doing so it's not the problem
it's not the trauma it's finding what
they value more than their problem and
and everyone has a place where there's
something that value more than their
trauma some people GA their trauma
because they realize I've been so
traumatized loss of this child that my
other child feels completely unloved and
they they realize I'm losing that love
I'm losing that child if I don't get my
[__] together right they need a higher
level of what's called Leverage Leverage
is what makes change a must not a should
as long as as it should you'll have your
story and your story could be a true
story and you'll tell your story and
share your story with yourself or other
people or both and you stay stuck but
trauma is you know it is not it's a
bruise it's not a tattoo right and HEB
bruise can be healed but not unless
you're vested in healing it and what a
lot of people do I I remember when I was
diagnosed with a tumor in my brain I've
seen this happen so much so I didn't
tell anyone I didn't even tell my spouse
at the time the first day I was trying
to process it cuz I didn't want people
start treating me differently and so the
only person who knew for the first day
or two was my assistant because she had
talked to the doctor so before I'd even
be able to tell my spouse at the time
all a sudden you know everyone treated
me like I was indestructible I taught
people to do that it's like cuz I want
to help everybody so there was no no
it's like I'll do whatever it takes
right so it was it was inhuman at the
time and suddenly my assistant started
saying you know we shouldn't book that
right now and we shouldn't do this right
now and I started getting love and
attention and connection we having this
problem I was like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa I'm not I'm not going to go down
that slippery soap but that takes a
really conscious mind to do it and and
lucky for me I've had a chance to deal
with millions of people so I see these
patterns all the time but most people
their problem is their drug it's the
drug against the fear that I'm not
enough and I won't be loved even if they
go no it's me I'm so messed up what
they're really saying is reassure me
love me they're wanting that connection
through their problem so you got to
decide there's something you value more
than your problem when you decide that
you can make it happen my original
teacher was Jim ran when I met him when
I was 17 and I wanted to know why all my
fathers were broke because they were
good men you know I loved all four of my
fathers and um and I remember him saying
Tony we're all equal as Souls but we're
not equal in the marketplace I was like
what does that mean and he said well
think about it he goes you need to
become more valuable if you want to have
economic freedom he said you have to
work on yourself more more than anything
else and you have to work on in a way
where there's something you can do for
others better than anyone else or at
least more at better quality and he gave
me the example of like working at
McDonald's and he said you know if you
work at McDonald's you know you make
whatever it was in those days $5 an hour
whatever it was and he said you like
well yeah but that seems so unfair and
he goes yeah and teachers I gave the
example of teachers and there's these
billionaires you know that make a
billion dollars in a year hedge fund guy
you know and he said Tony the guy you
just mentioned he provided a 40% return
last year and that went to nonprofits
everything else he said that means those
organizations double their money almost
every two years he is adding massive
value hundreds of billion dollars so he
made a billion he goes this person is
doing a job that anyone can learn in 20
minutes or half a day so it's a
beginning job he said you got you got to
think of it as one thing it's all about
adding value how can you do more for
others than anybody else in the world
and that stuck with me I mean I was like
I I decided I wanted to do more for
others than anybody in the world in
order to do that I had to have certain
skills and I went after those skills and
I still do like it's a never ending
thing if you think you're a master
you're full of it right so I think
that's probably some of the best advice
I've received at least on life and
business and Direction and and it
affected my mission also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there the difference between making it
or not is psychology and skill you need
them both and honestly skill is the
smaller of the two I'm going to give you
a ton of strategies this week I'm going
to do psychology first and you're going
to see why as this day goes by because
you're going to discover when people
stand up and we figure out what's the
choke hold on their business 80% of the
time it's going to be their
psychology the Chokehold on the growth
of your business is the psychology and
skills of the leader
period that's it and if we change those
two things skills too marketing skills
Financial intelligence recruiting
training all those things we me those
two don't get me wrong we got to do the
skills also but I could give you every
skill how many of you have learned it
before that was invaluable from some
Source a mentor a coach an event a
university I don't know what and you
were excited about it and then you never
actually followed through who's done
this before say I listen knowledge is
not
power execution trumps knowledge every
day of the week my goal is make you
execute and I can't make you but I can
get you where you tap into that part of
yourself and that shift is the most
important shift of these few days all of
us we could take our work and think of
work as being like a gift I I personally
believe that one of the greatest gifts
outside my love that I can give another
human being is my labor but there's
three gifts of Labor you might have
within your nature meaning you can
Master anything but under stress people
tend to go back to their true nature and
there are three gifts of Labor that you
can give one of those gifts we might
call the gift of being an artist or a
talent or in another word for it be a
truly skilled
producer some people the reason you know
this is your gift is what you love to do
is to create a product or service and
deliver it to people and you're enamored
by that the woman over here who is doing
the work if you recall you know in
hospice she would be a perfect example
of an artist she's not in it she wants
to make money don't get me wrong but she
would never trade the money for the
impact
so when someone is in it as an artist
and by the way most businesses are
started by artists there's somebody who
was an amazing negotiator an amazing
fashion designer amazing code writer and
they said I work for this company and
they don't do a good job for customers
and I can do a better job I don't work
for them and they start their own
company thinking that the company's all
driven just by the sales or the
negotiation or the code or the fashion
but a company is much more complex than
that especially as it grows so an artist
is in it for the impact and yes they
want to make money don't get me wrong
but it's not the first thing and they
won't trade it when I talk to artists
about selling their business they look
at me like I'm trying to sell their
child the second gift you might have is
the gift of being a manager leader a
manager leader is someone who lives to
manage people and processes they love to
figure out how to maximize a business by
changing the gears creating a new
process working with people and those
people love it now they are not artists
in that their talend skill they're not
there delivering it directly to the
client they want to work on the people
that are directly they want to work on
the system that makes this business work
and so they think differently they're
inspired by different things they make
different decisions is one better or
worse than the other yes or no no
they're just different and by the way
you might say I have both those skills I
bet you do but they're not equal CU
they're different types of skills so you
might have them both but there's one
that is your true nature that when
things are going well you're going to go
back to it when things are really up
you're going to go back to it under
stress and under excitement we return to
our Nature by the way a great company
can't be great without great artists
Talent who really deliver extraordinary
products or Services a company cannot
maintain greatness and grow unless they
have some great manager leaders who can
run with the process and the people
they're both critical components the
third choice of service the true gift
you can give is that of an entrepreneur
and while most of you in this room would
call yourself an entrepreneur and you
would be entrepreneurial
by this definition it's a little
different most people think of an
entrepreneur as anybody starts multiple
businesses no that's not true some
artists are multiple businesses because
they want to get all kinds of things for
all kinds of people some managers want
to do multiple businesses so they feel
like they got multiple systems but
entrepreneurs in it for one thing the
juice of risk they want to make money
and by the way an entrepreneur will they
sell this business yes or no for the
right price they'll sell anything and
their mindset is it sell it I'll start
another one sell it I'll buy another one
they are not attached they might enjoy
the product service they might be proud
of the product or service but they're in
it for the risk and they're the kind of
person that when they lose massively
they jump up dusts off and want to do it
again what's the most powerful pattern
of all you've heard me talking about it
before that changed Humanity that took
us from starving running around as
hunter gatherers to where we could stay
in one place it was one distinction what
was it recognizing the
seasons and understanding see before
that it was looked random you planted in
the winter you didn't even know it was
Winter you just knew it was cold and for
some reason you worked your ass off and
you got nothing for it and what I began
to look at here is like Humanity once it
understood the seasons and knew when to
plant when not to if you do the right
thing at the wrong time what kind of
reward do you get zilch nothing so all a
sudden Humanity understood this and now
we could stay in one place we could
build a community we could build cities
we could build countries but that one
distinction changed all of humanity but
there's also the seasons of your own
life that's so valuable to understand
think of it as four seasons of your life
0 to 20 roughly is your Springtime but
that initial Springtime you're learning
you're growing probably protected you're
absorbing things that's the stage some
people starts at 16 14 some say 1920 but
let's just call it around 21 you enter a
different stage of life you become kind
of the soldier of life you enter the
summertime 21 to 41 that's a different
stage isn't it now you go out in the
world and say I'm going to test this
stuff I was told all this what's true
and you think you're going to be a
billionaire or 10 times billionaire and
you're going to be president United
States and you're going to have a 100
relationships and it's all going to work
out smoothly and then you get your first
relationship and discover none of that
is true and you start to understand that
you have vulnerabilities find out you're
not invincible so this young adult Al
hood is testing and discovering just
trying to figure out what's really real
that's when we learn a lot and usually
some of it is painful because it's not
quite like we expected but you're the
soldier of society quite literally
that's where soldiers are right 21 to 41
usually right you're the person that
goes to war you're the person that's out
there doing the hard work now if you
really grew in Spring and you really
grew in summer then there's the fall the
Autumn and that means 42 to 62 is a real
reaping time if you've grown if you're
not grown like if you don't plant in the
spring you're going to weep in the fall
you're not going to reap in the fall
right but if you push through the hot
summer it's difficult time those 21 to
41 by the way when you ask people when
they do all the research on people
what's the most unhappy time of their
life it's that two decades not for every
human but for most cuz trying to figure
out who the hell you are prove to
yourself make it through all the
[__] trying to figure what's going
on in your life but when you get to 42
to 62 again if you've grown if you've
not grown you're kind of scented there's
not much crop but now you're really in
your midlife power and you get to start
to have a harvest time this is for a lot
of people their greatest Financial time
of their life because they built up
understanding and they worked hard and
developed skill sets and now they're in
a position to lead they might start
running an organization they start to
really grow to expand and then 63 to 83
you can think of as winter an 83 to 120
is the oldest living humans if you're
fortunate enough maybe you'll have an
extended winter but in this stage you
really end up being a leader who's
really there to Mentor that's really the
position you're in it's like what I love
most now it's like the example I give
you of playing a video game against the
child you know the child's always going
to win and it's not cuz they're faster
and smarter it's because they played
this game a million times they know the
first bad guys here the next bad guys
here next bad guys here so they're able
to do something really important is this
is what today is all about if you want
and simple phrase anticipation is
power anticipation is power leaders
anticipate losers
react if you and I are going to have a
great quality of life for our families
for our
communities for anybody we want to serve
our job is to anticipate in order to do
that you got to recognize patterns so
these seasons of your life are precious
every season has different challenges
right how many can remember some of the
challenges of the Springtime of your
life I remember some of the challenges
of the summer in that stage the things
you wrestled with some are still there
how many remember the fall
experiences right so everything has
opportunity every has Challenge and if
you can anticipate the challenge you can
make that season h of a lot more
enjoyable a lot of the generation that
you see today you know the you know Z
generation not so much cuz they're just
coming up right but the millennial
generation my older people they see them
as weak you know there're snowflakes or
this and they're that but they have
technology they have insights and when
the outside world is demanding enough
not yet because they're still
fearful they will grow and that's when
things change and so the season occurs
so think about the difference between
the 30s and the 40s versus the
50s versus the 60s as we came after 63
into an American Summer is a different
mindset versus the 80s to the 2000 20110
so we're right now halfway through
winter we're in another winter it starts
financially now it's gone to health but
we're far from it it's going to be war
and it might be cyber War it might be
full-on War but there's zero question
that China and the US are on a collision
course that's going to shape the
direction of humanity and so the people
that right now are alive today are going
to have to grow in that environment I
really think we're at a season where
there's going to be a whole new level of
growth and what I just want to do is be
one of them many sources that can give
people perspective because here's the
problem a year ago people thought we
were coming out of you know we got
vaccines now and we're coming out of Co
and it's going to be all over now people
are cited but now after going through
two years of this there's a lot of
people now that no longer have a
compelling future like you know people
talking about New Year's resolutions
most people don't even have one because
it's like they never follow through
anyway right but at least they had
something to look forward to they're
starting to get a learned helplessness
learned helplessness is something is so
bad over and over again you start
thinking the problem's permanent no
problem is permanent or you start
thinking the problem's pervasive because
I haven't handled my finances my whole
world's over or because my
relationship's bad my whole world's over
your life is bigger than that or all
this is happening because there's
something wrong with me when you get to
that point you stop trying and so my
goal right now is to shake that up for
people people need a new perspective and
you can't do it by just sitting and
thinking you got to move your body you
got to change your energy and your focus
cuz low level of energ I don't D how
smart you are you're not going to use
all your ability but if I get you into a
higher state of being mentally
emotionally physically and all of a
sudden you start remembering who you are
and you start coming up with answers
that you never even thought were
possible before everybody knows about
placebos right mhm they only discovered
in World War II and it was discovered by
accident this doctor ran out of morphine
and he's treating these these people
that are badly injured and you know you
need the morphine not just so they're
out of pain but so they don't go into
shock M and the actual person who
discovered this gets no credit was a
nurse cuz the nurse hand him a syringe
and said we've got some more morphine so
he believed it and he said you'll be out
of pain in just less than a minute he
injected them and in every case none of
them went into shock 90% of them were
out of pain and they used nothing it was
saline right so after World War II he
went back to Harvard and he was the
person that created what we now consider
to be the double bind studies which are
always compared to a placebo right and
what most people don't know is the
bigger the placebo intervention the more
powerful the Mind believes it so a small
pill is less effective than a big pill
um an injection is more powerful than a
pill in terms of its Effectiveness the
most powerful is a is a sham surgery um
the the Veterans Administration did a
study and they did on people doing knee
surgeries and they took one-third of the
people and they just cut them open
anesthesized them and S the backup did
nothing A year later this group the
group that had no surgery had the least
amount of pain the most amount of
flexibility the most amount so they stop
funding those surgeries to give you an
idea but that's how powerful it is and
so when you it's even more than Harvard
did a study where they took barbituates
made these big red pills and said this
is an amphetamine you need to prepare
your body because you're going to speed
up they didn't give him something fake
they give him an actual drug that slows
the body down and the body sped up so
most people don't understand the power
of the mind and so what I tried to do is
show people even in this book here are
the things that you can do to take
control of your mind because if you take
care of your body and then you don't
take care of your mind and emotions
you're going to be miserable 41 years of
my life I've been obsessed with trying
to find the ways to help people have a
greater quality of life whatever that is
for them life on their terms not my idea
of what a quality of life is but theirs
and you know people come to me all the
time and come to events and they want to
transform their business or they want to
transform their body or they want to
rebuild or deepen a relationship or
create one or they just want to feel Joy
or happiness we're all pursuing all
these things but really it's just this
experience of life
life at its highest level that we're all
searching for and over the last few
decades you know early in my life it I
figured I didn't have much control of my
external World there was so much
suffering that I figured I got to master
that and so I worked hard and for
decades learning from the smartest
people I could how could I achieve
succeed break through master myself push
myself and all those tools you could
call maybe the science of achievement
it's like how do you take what you
envision and make it real how do you go
from you know having possibility to
actually creating that in your life but
as I experienced that over the decades I
also noticed that so many people who are
great Achievers were just not happy I
mean I go to India I usually go about
every 12 to 18 months and I remember
when I first went there I was like this
poverty was overwhelming to me and and
it was so confusing to see people so
happy you know because all around them
they seem to have such squalor i' see
someone sitting in the street and there
was just so much joy in their eyes if
you took the time to feel them and talk
with them instead of judging the
environment and then I come home to the
United States where there's all this
external abundance and you'd find people
you know many of you know I I wrote
money Master of the gam you 50 of the
smartest Financial people in the world
self-made billionaires and not I
wouldn't say the majority of them are
really happy and it has nothing to do
with the money it's that the internal
world was not mastered so if there's two
Sciences or two Master skills I think in
life that we want it's if we took east
and west and put them together and we
didn't make the other one wrong we'd say
hey it's mastering the science of
achievement but also the art of
fulfillment and of the two
for the last four or five years I've
been traveling the country really trying
people to get people to feel and
experience the beauty that comes when
what's inside is great regardless of
what's outside the outside world will
never make you happy long term what you
get will never make you happy who you
become what you experience what you give
that's what makes us really happy most
of us have been conditioned not to take
a risk people ask me all the time what
does it take to be happy and I always
tell them it's really simple one word
progress progress equals Happ happiness
if you keep growing you're going to feel
alive and if you keep growing you're
going to have more to give and when
you're growing and giving is when life
is magnificent it doesn't matter how
many statues Oscars they give you or EMS
or how much money you have in the bank
we've all seen people had all those
things and I get the phone call because
they're depressed or somebody commits
suicide in that area so it's really an
inner game and I think that's what's
missing for us today everybody's
focusing on the outside world and Hell
there's a lot of things in the outside
world you'll never be able to control
you can influence but you can't control
it this your mind your emotions your
body you have 100% control over what you
do with these things and that's where
the game is won you win the inner game
then you win the outer game but a lot of
people spent their life trying to win
the outo game they won and they're
miserable so to me success without
fulfillment is the ultimate failure and
so many people are focused on success
still which to me is like there's
nothing wrong with it but it's like
success is getting what you want
fulfillment is living What You're Made
for you know and it's like fulfillment
and success they're not even the same
universe there's nothing wrong with
going for success but you you really got
to figure out what you're made for and
nobody knows in the beginning so you
start where you are and you do what's in
front of you do what's next then you
keep growing until you start to discover
hey this is my real passion this is my
real hunger and drive and it can change
people go for five six seven years and
then they usually question their
business their career their their body
their relationships and then of two
things happens they change direction and
feel renewed or they go no I got a great
deal here what the hell's wrong with me
and they recommit and they get stronger
but that's life and if you don't grow I
don't give damn how much you got going
for you're going to be miserable it's
always been impact for me I love people
I'm somebody asked my mom was he always
like this she's passed away but she
always to tell the story so I'd hear her
version of the story and you know we
grew up in kind of the hood of La a
really rough ter territory and on a
commercial Street in this crappy little
house there was a lot of violence around
there but right next door was this old
liquor store and we were poor and she
was pregnant with my brother I was
almost four and a half I guess years old
5 years old and you know I would go to
that place to get stuff because we had
nobody else my father was an underground
parking attendant so he wasn't there so
it was she and I and so I guess she sent
me next door to get bread and milk which
we desperately need we had very little
money I guess I was gone for a very long
time where she was woring I come back
with no bread and milk and she said
where's the bread and milk and I said
well there's a poor boy there so I gave
him our money and she says
you know so I've always had that and I
think there's an old movie called Mr
Holland Opus I use it sometimes to date
with Destiny and there's a line in the
movie with this man his whole life was
about you know writing this great Opus
and how they make him rich and famous
and all these things and he becomes a
school teacher not because he likes kids
but because he gets off at 3M and has
his Summers off thinks he's goingon to
write this office and I almost I I cry I
think about right now because it's just
what life's about you know life's about
love life's about people but there's
this moment when he loses his job
because they cut the music program and
he decides he's going to retire and he's
leaving with his wife and his kid who's
deaf he's you know the movie I am very
familiar I right now every time we watch
it you know you see this man come and
he's at the latter years of his life and
all of a sudden as he's leaving there's
this sound in the gym and they he goes
what does that sound he goes no and it's
after hours he goes to open up the gym
and there's all these students from all
the years of his 25 years of teaching or
30 years of teaching whatever it was and
they're all cheering and he comes down
and and he's just stunned by the
response and his wife gets up and says
you know a lot of people heard about you
the retirement of my husband and I can't
believe the Outreach and so we wanted to
let him know how much he's loved and and
then all of a sudden the doors open and
this little redhead girl who he had
blasted in the beginning cuz she had no
talent in like clarinet yeah um but he
then fell in love with trying to support
her and it's when he became a better man
she's now an adult and she's the
governor of the state and she goes
bursting in goes oh I'm sorry I thought
we were a little bit running late she
comes up and she looks at him and gets
on stage and she does this little speech
but the essence of it is um Mr Holland's
touched all of us so much but she says
um um you know Mr Holland had this Opus
he was going to write he and word was it
was going to make him rich and famous
but he's neither
at least not outside this small town but
she said but if he just got those riches
in Fame he would have missed out on what
he has here and she says look around you
Mr Holland these are the notes of your
music this is the Symphony of your life
and um sorry I again emotionally was so
silly emotional guy that's why I do what
I do because I get to
see um people's lives change I get to
see moms reclaim themselves I see
children you know stand up for
themselves I see men who become men
again and really step up and take the
responsibilities that make them feel
alive I see people build businesses and
I see people happy again I see couples
coming together I see joy and happiness
not because life is always like that but
because they can find meaning even when
it's painful and to me to live a
life what that kind of meaning is a gift
from God if you look at a person's life
most people major and minor things
Jim R and my teacher used to say that to
me all the time meaning they know about
all kinds of things that don't matter
but there's maybe a half dozen things
that matter most there's your body
there's your emotions there's your
relationships there's your finances
there's your career or your sense of
mission or your business and then
there's the spiritual side of life and
so I've always taught on all those areas
but in 2008 when all hell broke loose
the first time um you know I've worked
with Paul tutor Jones one of the top 10
financial traders for now 25 years 26
years and so I I knew a little bit this
area most people don't know I know the
details of you know a lot man hearing
you talk about Finance you are
freakishly knowledgeable I've seen you
on stage with people that make a living
doing it and not only do you keep up in
many ways I think they're listening to
you as closely as you're listening to
them at this point how do you learn that
stuff that deeply well you know I go for
total immersions like if you learn
language a little bit at a time you know
two three years from now you don't speak
the language but if I dumped you into
Rome and said you're not leaving for 8
weeks and there's no teacher you're
going to be speaking Italian before you
leave there so I'm a big believer in
total immersion but I also believe in
modeling the best on Earth so in money
Master the game fortunately I have
access so it's like I'm going to
interview 50 of the smartest Financial
people on Earth and everybody who's made
it from nothing to multi-billionaire and
they all did it different ways and I'm
good at pattern recognition and I'm good
at pattern utilization in fact I would
say to your audience you know in 2040
which sounds like a long way from now 18
years ago like that you your mind will
be blown half the jobs we have today
according to Oxford and a variety of
other universities are going to be gone
they're replaced by robotics by
algorithms you know the game and so the
bottom line is you need to be good at
pattern recognition and that's what gets
somebody strong at anything I me you
look at you know why is Amazon doing so
well he realized one pattern was valued
over anything else convenience right if
you look at Tom Brady friend of mine he
he's got pattern recognition like nobody
else at 43 years old he's able do things
no one dreamed could be done he's got
more Super Bowl rings than any team so I
said I want to go to the best people on
Earth and see what do they see that none
of us see what's the pattern then you
got to learn pattern utilization it's
one thing to see it it's nothing thing
to use it and then if you're good after
while you get to pattern creation it's
like if you learn to play the piano most
people play other people's music and
then there's a point you've learned so
much that you're able to create and I
think those three skills are the most
important skills so I look at the areas
that matter most and say who already has
that extraordinary pattern recognition
utilization so I go to Ray doio who's
you know return more money to investors
than anyone alive you know he's going to
have a different level of understanding
than the average person and because I
MERS myself so much most of these
interviews are supposed to be 30 minutes
and the average one was three and a half
hours and so but like Ray D is now a
dear friend of mine I can pitch and
catch with him because I came so
overprepared and because I could again
not just catch the ball he threw but
pitch it back and so to me that's what I
did I did for to immersion it was a 3
and 1/ half year project and then
expanded I wrote you know uh unshakable
after that because I saw what was going
to happen in the markets and I wanted
people prepared you got to have
something that is large enough that
makes you crazy and you don't know that
you can do it but you got to know you
can do it I know it sounds ridiculous
there's got to be some part of you that
turns it into a must not a should if
it's a should it gets done when it's
easy when it's a must it happens no
matter what and you know the difference
between should and must is reasons
reasons come first answers come second
if you got strong enough reasons if you
got a big enough why you can figure out
how to do anything but what keeps people
I think from making moonshots real
because you got to look at the side of
why people don't do it or why they don't
follow through I think number one that
people they the first question people go
to is how and that's the wrong question
how is absolutely the wrong question to
start with because if you've never done
it before what that produces uncertainty
if you have uncertainty then you don't
execute at the same level it's like
people say knowledge is power we all
know that [__] right execution is
power knowledge is potential power
execution beats knowledge every day of
the week so my bias is towards action
even it's wrong action you're going to
learn quicker than if you do nothing but
the challenge is people are asking how
and that produces uncertainty what you
got to ask is what and why if you know
what needs to be done and why it needs
to be done if it's strong enough then
there's a level of certainty that will
show up in your nervous system and
you'll be able to inspire other people
as well because you can't fake it
everybody can feel it and so if you can
come up with that and find out how to
turn that certainty on that's what I do
with people athletes business people
everybody is how do you turn that on and
keep it on turn that on and then knowing
what and why you can figure out how it's
like you know John F Kennedy didn't know
how to get to the moon when he said
we're going to put somebody on the moon
and return the Earth safely in this
decade and people in NASA are like he's
insane we don't have the resources but
they did it that's leadership that's a
moonshot right and it can't just be you
so that's the other part is it something
that doesn't just inspire you is it
something that'll keep you going when it
doesn't look like it's going to work
keep you from giving up but is it
something that'll get other people to
join you otherwise it's just you and
you're you're not going to do it by
yourself there's no moonshots that are
done by individuals that's bull
individuals may stimulate it but it
takes a team it takes an army of people
to make something happen so I think
watch out for the tyranny of How It's
tyranny don't start with how it'll it'll
shut down your capacity start with what
and why and get that so strong then
start brainstorming there's a million
house and and if there isn't a way you
can find a way or make a way people
think they have to know how I call it
the tyranny of how like you get all
excited I'm going to do this and then
your brain goes I've never done it
before Oh my God what did I say I don't
know how to do this and they tend to
focus on how to do it and when you start
with how you're screwed like Martin
Luther King had no idea how when he did
his IE of a Dream speech in fact his
wife was the one that pushed him because
he was uncertain right if you know the
real history it's pretty interesting but
the bottom line is he gets up there and
he gives his vision of how it can be
done he talked about what needs to
happen and why if you can figure out
what you want and why you want it and
you get strong enough reasons reasons
that'll drive you late at night it'll
get you up early in the morning and the
reasons are different some people do it
for nitty-gritty reasons Jim Ron used to
say because you know some guy told him
he he borrowed money from this finance
company I forget the name of hfc Finance
whatever the hell it was and you know he
hadn't been back since he borrowed the
money you know so they're calling him in
those days they could harass you in ways
they can't today right they call him
show up embarrass him in front of his
neighbors and so Jim ran his first real
chunk of money he told me he made
because it's like he set this goal it
was his nitty-gritty reason his reason
to get rich was so we could go down and
pay this thing off and he said he went
to the bank and got it all in cash and
in small bills and he pull it into this
little hfc you know Finance place and
the guy who borrow the money was the
fourth best back in he said I walked up
there I open I opened up this brief and
I dumped all the money all over his desk
in small bills and I said count it it's
all there I will never be back he said
he was startled because I hadn't been
there since I borrowed the money right
but but he did it for that he GRE some
people do it for their kid some people
will do it like we'll almost all do it
for something more than ourselves some
people do it because they like winning
right I know that about you right it's
like I like winning I like being the
best at what I do so I'm not going to
settle for less than that why would I
right so you got to find your reasons
but if you know what you want and you
get a big enough why now you'll figure
out how to do it but if you start with
how you know the small brain the fear
brain goes oh [__] I don't know what to
do I don't know where to go I don't know
what to do 90% of time either I know
what and why and then I try some it
doesn't work I try something else I
something else now I speed it up by
learning from the best so that's why you
know money Master the game is a perfect
example my companies you know at the
time were h million companies I had one
$500 million company now we're doing 7
billion I took what I learned from these
guys I applied it not only in my
investing I applied it to my own
businesses why do I reinvent the wheel
when I just learned from the best on
Earth I mean somebody's that good can
tell you that little 2 mimer thing that
changes everything so my life is really
about learn from the best but I don't
start with a how I start with the what
and the why and I think that's the
mistake most people make great ideas are
never going to interrupt you they have
to be pursued and you if you don't
pursue them you're going to get what
everybody else has which is all this
fear all this uncertainty all this stuff
who won't work because everybody's
focused on what won't work what can't
happen why because they're afraid
they're afraid to fail they're afraid to
try and feel like they're not enough so
you got to stand guard of that Mind by
feeding your mind you know Jim R used to
say to me success leaves Clues if you
want thing to get better you got to get
better if you want things to change you
got to change but you got to do it
deliberately and consciously and he used
to say to me constantly he said Tony
you've got to constantly find a way to
feed that mind something that's got
strategy in it philosophy something
that's going to improve the quality of
your life and if you really learn it you
can help the people you love with the
things you learn and so I got hooked and
so I decided I'm G to read a book a day
I took a speed reading course and I
didn't read a book a day but I read 700
books over the period of seven years all
in the area of philosophy physiology
emotion the things to me that mattered
most and what I really try to do is each
day try to use something I learn not
just read not just let my learning lead
to knowledge you know Jim used to say if
you let your learn lead to knowledge you
become a fool if you let your learn lead
to action that's when your life changes
so I started being aware of who was
saying what what I was taking in you
know Jim used to say you know success
leaves Clues if someone's successful
they're not lucky they're doing
something different than you figure out
what they're doing different and he said
the first thing is find out what they're
reading he said because he said I
remember he said to me something funny
he said find out what poor people read
and don't read it and when he said poor
he didn't just mean financially poor he
meant people that were unhappy people
that were had no sense of meaning in
their life people that were financially
strapped because they weren't managing
to add value to other people people that
found themselves not taking care of
their relationships their body poor
isn't just money wealth isn't just money
it's emotional spiritual everything he
said so find out what successful people
do what wealthy people read what happy
people read that one of the things you
have to understand about life is
everything changes and everything ends
and that kind of sounds heavy on the
front end but it's a truth if everything
changes and everything ends number one
it should make you appreciate what you
have right now and then my view is
what's next is always better if I make
it so it's my job to make it so and so I
think you know for me I look at it and
say you know when you said uh genius is
a young man's game I think that's total
[__] um I think passion is the
Genesis of Genius if you've got enough
passion you're going to find answers
nobody else does but most people run out
of fuel meaning they get tired they get
exhausted they get burned out they get
uh you know the law of familiarity
they're around something so much they
take it a little bit for granted and
I've managed to see something in myself
that I found in every great leader that
I've ever respected and that is I I I
value intelligence immensely but I know
really smart people can't fight their
way out of a paper bag pragmatically
right I'm sure you do too what I see is
the one common denominator of people
that are successful over a lifetime is
the sustained hunger Hunger is the
number one factor most of us in life we
we work so hard for things we think
life's going to be a certain way but as
you're going to discover life is never a
straight line you know we're Tau that we
think line is just I'm going to go from
here to there but if you look in nature
you never see a straight line in real
nature if it's a straight line of human
built it and so it's a process of
evolving of growing dropping back
growing dropping back and and challenges
are what really grow us you know your
life is a great story you know every
person's life is a story and the
question is some people's story is a
warning some people's story is an
example right now you're an example
that's growing and expanding and you
have a chance to have this be the most
incredible life but it won't be a life
without Challenge and the challenges
we're facing right now give you an
opportunity to grow like very few
Generations you know I'm sure you've
heard of the great generation the World
War II generation if you watch a great
movie if you read a great book
you know the size and the power of the
hero how much you become as a hero is
defined by how tough an obstacle you
face how difficult is the villain the
opponent and so sometimes when I've been
through the toughest times in my life
one of the questions I've had to ask
myself or note to myself is ah I finally
have a really worthy opponent this is
scaring the hell out of me or this is
challenging me or this is making me
crazy but I also know in my gut and my
soul that if I can push through this
just like you've done in these years
you've pushed through tough times I'm
sure many of them but as you push
through those you become more and as you
become more something magical happens
you don't just grow you expand in your
spirit and your soul and your capacity
and your skill and all of a sudden fear
becomes less and less a part of you
ultimately I really believe that the
probably the most I don't know the most
sacred thing in our lives that we can
give another human being besides our
love is our labor you think about it
your labor is your energy it's your time
it's your emotion it's your intellect
it's your spirit Spirit to some extent
and if you can find a way where what you
do for a living activates that sense of
what you're made for then work is not
work whether you be in thei or whether
you be in a an environment that might be
seem less exciting and promising in the
moment trust me I worked in plenty of
those too but with the same level of
excitement and passion because I found
what turns me on that makes me feel
alive makes me feel like I'm doing
something that's worthwhile and on Labor
Day I think a lot of people it's just a
holiday to get away and take time off of
Lab Labor uh and my hope is to trigger
you to think about how could you turn
your labor into your love I think it was
uh Mark Twain said when your vocation
becomes your vacation that's when life
becomes truly magnificent and um I'm
privileged enough to have that but I
pursued it and one of the secrets that I
found and I know you know this in your
soul is that we all know if you're going
to be masterful at something you don't
show up you know as the best in the
world at something you don't show up in
environments that you want to be in you
get there because you did things for
thousands and thousands of hours most of
you know the concept of Mastery taking
10,000 hours that's an arbitrary number
but I'm sure you've heard about it you
want to get really good at something
it's 10,000 hours because when you do
something enough with enough intensity
enough intention to constantly get
better when your labor is your love and
where your labor is something you have
to always get better at then usually
what happens is you get these insights
that allow you to serve more but I also
think that labor you know talking about
this weekend what makes people fulfilled
by their labor is is their motives for
it if your motive is just to make money
or just to pay your bills or or just to
get rich or whatever you think that's
going to be those people never really
are fulfilled even if they make the
money um the most fulfilled human beings
in my experience and and I've had the
privilege of working with literally 4
million people from 125 countries now
around the world the people that are
most alive regardless of the economics
are people that have found something
that they really feel the motive is more
than just themselves you know we all
know what it feels like when you're
trying to do for something for someone
you love and you're not doing it as a a
trade you're not trying to get something
back you're just doing it because it's
What You're Made for and um I always
tell people motive does matter that if
you're just doing something for yourself
there's nothing wrong with that because
life supports whatever else supports
life if you're part of life and you're
trying to do something that's going to
make your life better I think the
universe God whatever proper term for
you whatever your belief system is you
know infinite intelligence gets
connected to you and it gives you
insights but I think if you're trying to
serve more than yourself more than just
you when things support more of life
more of Life shows up to support you and
that might sound kind of Airy fairy but
it's my experience you know when you're
trying to support your family when
suddenly I had four kids three of them
overnight my life changed my intellect
changed my abilities changed because I
was trying to serve something more than
just me uh when I started really
focusing on how to serve a community and
then a country and then Humanity with
corny at may sound um you get insights
you won't get when you're just trying to
somehow you know make your labor happen
or get the job done so labor could be
love and it isn't for most people most
people I think are unhappy in their life
because they look at Labor as work uh
they look at as why should I have to
effort so much and in my experience
effort is the reward if you are doing
something you love it's there so if you
don't have it you might say Tony that's
all wonderful you're in Fiji and you do
what you love and I don't have that
thanks so much for giving me the lecture
I'm not coming from that place I'm
coming from the place of saying you can
discover something that you're really
passionate about but in order to do it
you got to get out of the story of what
you can't do and you got to put yourself
on the line we are made to grow if we
don't grow it doesn't matter how much
money you made doesn't how many people
gave you Academy Awards stars on your
chart I mean I get the phone calls from
all these people who you would think
have the greatest life in the world and
then they're calling me because it's not
so great because they haven't mastered
the inner world they're good at the
outer world but this one this one hasn't
been given enough time or energy they've
been so focused out here and they've
done so well out here not so well in
here this is the one you want to do well
on you do well here you can Master the
outside world too you can handle
anything so for me it really comes down
to looking at it and saying okay if you
and I are going to have an extraordinary
level of fulfillment what's going to
make me grow because that's what's going
to make me proud and to grow you got to
face challenges and I think the biggest
problem most people have is the biggest
problem they have is they think they
shouldn't have problems you know it's
like problems are a sign of life
problems are what make you grow now you
know I'd rather call it a challenge I'd
rather look it as a challenge and it on
as a challenge but you and I both know I
mean I have grown so much in the last 24
months taking 105 companies some of
which were literally shut down for you
know 12 months keeping them alive not
letting go of my employees figureing way
to turn around figure how to adapt I
mean I developed more skill and ability
to help other people because I had to
manage my own State unbelievably so I
had to help other people manage their
state so without the challenge what I
grow so much probably not find the
blessing and that sounds corny to some
people but you you know when you think
about your life these last three or four
years with covid and so much fear and
crime and everything that you if you
watch the news for five minutes you feel
like there is no future it's not to say
there aren't challenges out there
they're real but we don't experience
life we experience the life we focus on
what's wrong is always available so is
what's right and so it's really
important to find the blessing and
whatever challenges you've gone through
I know many of you went through Co it
was pretty horrific but many of you
actually found a way to use Co to do
something greater with your family or
life or make some career changes or life
changes and so life is going to give us
challenges no matter what but it's our
job to find the blessing to see that
maybe everything in life is really
happening for us not to us even though
it looks like that and so we we sent you
a little video of our friend Madu to
give you an example of somebody finding
those blessings and then the second part
was to really be a blessing we often say
you know the secret to living is giving
but it's not just gifts it's presence
it's caring it's guidance as simple as
those things are they also change you um
you get in the habit of doing that
because it's our nature when we're not
stressed you all of a sudden find a
balance you find a balm within yourself
as well as you're being a balm to other
people if you constantly find the
blessings in life you look for what's
right instead of what's wrong if you're
constantly trying to be a blessing to
other people then you'll be blessed and
that's not corny it's just it's the law
of reciprocation in life we all get what
we put out and often tfold and it can
happen either way negative or positive
so it's part of our life is to really
it's not even about religion it's about
Grace it's understanding that you know
Grace will flow to you if you are
pouring out Grace to others if you're
constantly giving and sharing and so we
know you know these things they're not
new to say the least but this time of
the year is a great time of the year to
reinforce them in yourself and maybe
with your children or your family talk
to me about what causes depression well
rather than me answer that question the
head of the
nihd or however they pronounce it but he
said you know in 22 years uh I spent
whatever it was $20 billion did some of
the most interesting studies in the
world and we didn't move uh you know one
person out of depression the bottom line
is biochemistry is hard of it but it is
related to what we focus on what we feel
I can change your biochemistry in a
heartbeat close your eyes and have you
imagine one thing I can disrupt you
produce fear close your eyes produce
something else we can produce a
parasympathetic effect a calming effect
so you cannot separate the mind and the
body they're together and so my Approach
is both I think you know from going to
events I believe in physiology first but
it isn't just biochemical it's the way
you move it's the way you breathe it's
the way you gesture if I said to you
there's a depressed person behind
curtain number one over here and I'll
give you a $100,000 donation to your
favorite charity if you can describe
their posture everyone knows what's
their posture like where where's their
head down down where's the shoulders
slouch are they breathing full or
shallow shallow that's right are they
talking loud or quiet soft fast or slow
slow how do you know cuz we've all
practice this at some point been
depressed right but if you take that
same person I don't care what's going on
with them and you put their shoulders
back I know this sounds absurd and you
have them breathe different and they
speak at a different Tempo and they move
their biochemistry changes like that so
you got to shift the way the body is
being used but then also you have to
create a compelling future this is the
way I look at I look at as five to
thrive and give you a little picture in
your head think of a triangle the first
base of three things the base of how you
use your body affects your depression or
your excitement if someone's depressed
or they're excited they use the body
differently they breathe differently
they move differently they speak
differently so you can make a
biochemical change just by changing the
body radically enough in the way you
move second is what you focus on
determines what you feel so if you're
supposed to meet your husband or wife at
700 p.m. for dinner and you get there
and they're not there boyfriend
girlfriend whoever what do you feel well
some people go I'm angry some people go
I'm worried well it's only 7 you know
well let say it's 7:30 and they've not
shown up they've not called they not
text well now some go I'm really worried
I'm really pissed off you know it's 8:30
if you haven't called you know I'm full
woman tells me right I didn't wait for
the bastard but my point is whether
you're angry or whether you're worried
those are biochemical effects but
they're all based on what you focused on
if you were really angry like they did
it again you know they're probably
screwing around with somebody else if
you imagine that in your mind you're
going to be upset but if you were
worried you thought what if they were in
a car accident and you're going to get a
very different biochemical effect but
people have had of what they focus on
and those habits become your biochemical
habits as well and so they reinforce
each other it's not a one-way street so
that's why you know I really believe
exercise is one of the most important
elements pushing someone beyond their
normal Comfort zones physiologically
while you simultaneously are working on
their head creating something so you
need strong physiology you need a really
clear Focus because you're only
experiencing what you focus on the human
brain is a distortion deletion and
generalization device your conscious
mind can only handle so many things at
once you're not thinking about your
clothing touching your skin or the you
know the sound of your heartbeat till I
mention it or let's say the you know the
sound of the in your ear of being able
to hear that heartbeat all those things
I have to call your attention to because
your brain is deleting most of what's
going on so it's not overwhelmed
consciously so we pay attention to a
small amount of things so if you're
really happy you're deleting all the
things that could piss you off or make
you worried if you're really worried
you're deleting all the things you could
be grateful or happy about so and we
tend to generalize Our Lives because
we're cognitive misers we don't want to
think things through so if you have
strong physiology strong Focus then the
third piece is meaning is what creates
emotion like if somebody says something
and you go they're disrespecting me or
they're challenging me or they're
coaching me or they're loving me well
whichever word you select for those
Sensations in your body your
biochemistry becomes and so you know
somebody might say oh you know this
happened to me cuz God's punishing me or
this happened to me cuz God's
challenging me or this problems here cuz
it's a gift from God or someone else say
it has nothing to do with God it's the
fact that I've been a lazy bastard right
whatever it is you do in your head there
is a biochemical effect so there's the
body there's the focus and there's
language those three shape how you feel
moment to moment if you're excited right
now using your body your focus and your
language in a different way than if
you're pissed off than if you're worried
Etc but then what makes you use these
three once you understand them is you
need what's called a compelling future
you need something that gets you to move
forward and like I feel so bad for the
generation today you know Z generation
Millennials because so many of them are
now talking about not even having
children because of the exaggeration of
the problems we've always had problems I
remember we're going to run out of oil
where the the ozone was going to be
destroyed in the 1970s the cover of Time
Magazine we've always had these
challenges and we've always learned to
adapt to these challenges whatever those
ch challenges may be but people today
think these problems are forever because
we've had some times here that we've
never had where we literally shut down
the whole world and had people trapped
in their homes and that has an effect on
people because they don't have a
compelling future so you have to develop
a compelling future and what allows you
to do that finally is what's under this
triangle if there's a circle think of a
compelling future and there's the power
of identity identity is who are you
beyond the problem there's something
inside you that's bigger than anything
that's ever happened to you that ever
could happen to you and tapping in and
finding that part of yourself is how you
get someone to have sustained strength
how have you been able to expand your
energy year-over-year what are some of
the simple tweaks that people could do
today I was a vegan for about 10 years
and then I ate uh fish and salad
basically for about 12 years so
dietarily I've always tried to make sure
that what I had was as clean as possible
to start with then I train like a crazy
person um you know I do oxygen
Restriction Training type of thing so
that my capacity is strong but I'm also
trying to train so I can literally do
two and 1 half marathons on a day and
then another day and another day another
day um for me the most important thing I
think has been for me is believe it or
not has been a combination of hot and
cold temperatures that I use like I
start every single morning in the
freezing water and I do it for two
reasons one is it moves every bit of
blood in your body and all your lymph in
your system but also kind of train my
brain to say when I say go we go you
know it's like it's there's never a day
I look forward to going in the water and
I have you know 56° water here but in my
home in Sun I go literally through the
snow and get in the river which is you
know like 39 40° in the winter time and
but you feel so incredible when you come
out but also it's just training your
brain saying I say go we go it's not
like oh I'm not ready yet or let me wait
five minutes and that becomes a
discipline in your mind for everything
else in your life which is huge and then
believe it or not
sonas just in the last year I've started
using saas they've seen a huge change
I've always known about sonas I use them
you know every now and then but there's
so much research on it now and have it
in the book that'll blow your mind like
four days a week in the sauna for just
20 minutes at 160 degrees plus whether
it's a you know a laser type sauna red
Sonic going in or or a traditional one
will absolutely change your health in
more ways you can imagine like people
that don't really work out I can get
them to do this now and they just go sit
in the sauna but what happens it reduces
your chance of a heart attack by over
51% I said that yeah W it reduces your
chance of a stroke by 62% your overall
health is reduced I mean it and then
here's the thing I've noticed that
happens that people I get doing this
they wouldn't work out now they do the
sauna and they put some music on or they
put a movie in the background or
something and the great thing is after
doing it for about a month sweating
everything else now they want to work
out now they want to do something else
so I look for the things the quick
little hacks that can make it happen in
my life I also use cryotherapy and
cryotherapy takes your body down to
minus 250 you know Fahrenheit takes out
like you know I used to ice myself cuz
after an event I've been you know
running up and down the stadium walls
and everything else every ounce of me 14
hours on stage 12 hours on stage stage
is gone and I go go ice like I did in
football you know 20 minutes on 20
minutes off it's painful but I had to do
it now I go in for 2 and a half minutes
in a cryotherapy unit and there's no
inflammation in my body it's just mind
bogging for people who have
osteoarthritis also uh like my
mother-in-law had such bad ostearthritis
even medications weren't helping her and
she was crying at night and I was like I
got to find an answer that's how I found
cry out then I started reading about
cryotherapy and started reading out
athletes doing it but I started reading
what it does for osteoarthritis she has
no pain now right so they're just tools
and you don't have to own one of these
things you know I'm fortunate enough to
have one here but you know you can go
there's local places all over the United
States all over the world now where you
can just go in five or 10 minutes and
it's amazing people just need to try it
out what would you say to someone with
fear well you don't have to manage you
got to stop thinking of yourself as
managing your circumstances and remind
yourself that you're a creator of your
life experience and so when it's winter
first of all it doesn't mean every
night's a bad day every day is a bad day
every dark day I live here in Florida
it's 78° and it's you know winter right
it's really nice so where you are what
you decide to do you it's all varying in
terms of the levels of winter as we just
talked about if you're in Africa right
now without food it's a very different
experience but I think the other part
for people really is you got to
understand there's two choices there's
fear and there's faith and as simplistic
as that sounds I ask people what's the
difference and they get confused and I
said it's really simple they're both
made up no one knows for sure what the
future looks like and by when I say the
seven or eight years it's not all just
tough econom IC times there's going to
be a confrontation with China maybe
there'll be a cyber War maybe some will
turn off your electricity but there's
zero question we're on target for that
if anybody wants to get a better
understanding they can read some of Ray
dal's work on the changing World Order
and understanding what's happened over a
thousand years of history but the point
of the matter is it's not all dark uh
that's number one but number two is
what's the differ between fear and faith
they're both
imagination but fear is Imagination
undirected it's like weeds just grows
automatically faith is you decide to be
certain you take action you follow
through there's no guarantee of anything
there's no guarantee I mean people run
around with a mask and they can walk
outside and get hit by a truck
Impossible Is Possible the more you can
give people an experience like Talk's
cheap but I've done enough things in my
life with enough people at this stage
I've got a track record where it's like
I said it's going to happen most people
say he's probably true it's probably
likely he's going to pull it off maybe I
should jump on board but the the mindset
has to be destroy any limitation and
move forward move forward move forward
there is a way move forward and I think
uh if you watch this it's like taking
off on a plane from you know I'm in
Texas right now if I flew from Dallas
here to go to Hawaii you off course
about 90% of the time I'm a pilot and
what if every time you off course oh my
God I'm off course oh freak out oh my
God I'm off course again but you know
you just tack back and forth and you
land exactly where you want to be 3 four
5,000 miles you know away and I think
that's how we have to navigate but most
of us and especially during these Co
times most of us have been conditioned
not to take a risk people ask me all the
time what does it take to be happy and I
always tell them it's really simple one
word progress progress equals happiness
if you keep growing you're going to feel
alive and if you keep growing you're
going to have more to give and when
you're growing in giving is when life is
magnificent it doesn't matter how many
statues Oscars they give you or EMS or
how much money you have in the bank
we've all seen people had all those
things and I get the phone call because
they're depressed or somebody commits
suicide in that area so it's really an
inner game and I think that's what's
missing for us today everybody's
focusing on the outside world and Hell
there's a lot of things in the outside
world you'll never be able to control
you can influence but you can't control
it this your mind your emotions your
body you have 100% control over what you
do with these things and that's where
the game is won you win the inner game
then you win the outer game but a lot of
people spent their life trying to win
the outer game they won and they're
miserable that fear that we're not
enough as is what's getting in the way
and you don't get over it you get Beyond
it and the way you get Beyond it is you
just train yourself and as you just said
that's why in the seminars it isn't just
the content it's putting you in a state
where the content can land and when you
put yourself in that state on a regular
basis those flows happen now you want
daily practices as well so you know
every day I've got a variety of daily
practices but one of those things I jump
in freezing cold water every day I think
you know but I don't do it because I
like it or I want it there's never a day
I look forward to it but I don't
hesitate I don't negotiate with myself
it's both physically great because it
flushes your blood and your lymph system
completely you feel like a million bucks
coming out of it going in it is painful
as hell but it's like I don't say in a
minute when I'm ready or maybe tomorrow
it's like I say go we go so it's a
mental training as well as it's a
physical training right and when you do
that over and over and then you say I'm
going to do this your brain doesn't
negotiate you've trained your own mind a
lot of people these discussions in their
own head back and forth and that's just
a habit all these things are patterns
you know I get up and I do my priming
which is putting myself in a state for
just 10 minutes a form of meditation but
it's a directed meditation I think of
three things I'm grateful for about a
minute each and I live them I don't
remember it over there I get in the
roller coaster as it's going down and
feel it and I get Associated to what I'm
most grateful for because gratitude
destroys the two emotions that mess up
your life which are fear and anger you
can't be angry and grateful
simultaneously
you can't be betiful and grateful so I
train my nervous system every day to
start with that then I do this form of a
prayer blessing then I do this three to
thrive which is a minute each on what I
really want to make happen but I don't
think about making it happen I see it as
done and complete and I train my brain
to feel celebratory in that area when
people don't do things it's not because
they can't it's not even because they
don't want to it's because of the way
they are focusing or what I call
chunking things
when people don't follow through here's
what they do give you an example who
here believes exercise is very important
but you don't exercise regularly let me
see it's your hands raise your hand more
hands than most of us want to raise our
hand right now who here really focuses I
should say exercises regularly raise
your hand regularly okay great who here
does not exercise regularly even though
you believe it's important just be
truthful okay great so let's see what
the difference is here a person who does
not exercise regularly I want you to
raise your hand and I want should tell
me why you don't exercise regularly be
truthful okay yes sir I don't have the
time I don't have the time now is that
true no he even knows it's not true he's
going to answer you first no but it
feels like he doesn't have the time
because time is emotion and he's got so
many other things he is focused on
getting results in that adding this to
the list seems like a lot right and the
other things are very important to him
like his business I don't have the time
he has the time what's the real reason
he doesn't do it because of the way he
thinks about exercise when he focuses on
what it would take to exercise he does
it very differently than someone who
follows through when you think about
exercising what's
involved at the moment about mile 14 of
London
Marathon quite painful okay he starts
thinking about I got to get to mile 14
of the London marathon and that even the
thought of trying to get to the 14th
mile much less the 25th mile is like
being on my imagination right now so he
is what I call over
chunked he's not thinking about what he
wants he's thinking about what's painful
he just saw a perfect example he's not
even thinking about Victory or
succeeding so the chance of him
following through on something that he
Associates major pain to when he can do
something else right now he can feel
competent or successful
at his chances of falling through are
very limited how many would follow that
say I his focus is on failure his focus
is on pain that's why he isn't following
through okay he's also focused on the
14th mile of a marathon rather than
today's
workout which one seems more daunting to
you so when you think of what it and
here's also what he's thinking about
he's thinking about the process not the
outcome or result he wants and when you
think about what it's going to take to
do something usually it takes a lot and
you're not going to want to do it so
he's over chunked himself he's trying to
eat the whale hole without taking any
smaller bites and it seems too big for
him so he says well I'll do it when
later CU my Australian friends would say
later right and of course the problem
with doing it tomorrow is when you get
to tomorrow tomorrow is today and
tomorrow never
comes so when you keep promising
Yourself by the way what does this do to
you emotionally when you keep breaking
your own promises with yourself or you
keep failing to do things that you know
are
important does it increase your L sevel
of certainty and
confidence no what it does is it roads
it and when you Road confidence in one
area believe it or not it affects the
other areas too do you believe me on
that don't believe me what about your
own life experience maybe not one area
but it starts to be multiple areas it
sure does another reason why somebody
doesn't exercise or do anything is
because they don't just chunk it too big
they chunk it in too many details I'll
give you a perfect example
so I asked somebody one time I said uh
okay how important is exercise is oh
exercise is extremely important really
okay good and tell me why don't you
exercise regularly well I and I just
don't have time okay everybody gives
that answer that sounds wonderful so
tell me though don't tell me about how
much time you don't have tell me this
when you think about exercising what do
you think about which is a way of saying
what do you focus
on and so this woman says to me well my
gosh you know I mean I what what do you
mean what do I think about well let's
say I said to you you you got to start
exercising and I'm going to put a gun to
the head of your children and I will do
very horrible things and hurt them badly
if you don't exercise could you do it oh
yeah I could do it you know if I if you
if some Mafia person came here and said
I'm going to kill your children if you
don't exercise every day how many think
you could find a way to exercise every
day no matter what your time constraints
may be so remember this remember this
change is never a matter of ability it's
always a matter of
motivation I'll say that again change is
never a matter of ability it's always a
matter of motivation or drive having
strong enough reasons if you got a
strong enough reason you could figure
out the time couldn't you so the biggest
part of life and time management is
knowing what you want and having enough
reasons to follow through but there is
one more piece if you make enough
reasons to follow through and you know
what you want but you make the task
overwhelming you'll be overwhelmed if
you're obsessed you know what you want
you're taking Massive Action maybe you
modeled somebody figure out the right
action so get there quicker and you're
executing you still need a little Grace
some people call it luck you could call
it God but I really believe that there's
the part we do and then there's the part
that comes to us but I do know Grace
shows up a lot more when you do the
first two steps on your own and Grace
shows up a lot more when you acknowledge
Grace in your life when you acknowledge
that I was born in a world where I
didn't have to build this internet that
I can pull out of my pocket the answer
anything on Earth I driving on streets I
didn't pave I'm reading books I didn't
have to write
that's the gift of our lives and I think
when we experience that Grace we don't
just experience more achievement but we
start to experience more fulfillment and
Grace not only affects your ability to
get there but it affects what you do and
how you you live once you are there it
really determines the quality of your
life because unless you live in a state
of gratitude you know I I did an
interview um with Sir John Templeton who
as you know is one of the first
billionaire investors and just a
brilliant man he came from nothing and
he donated I think it was 750 they still
do it Templeton fund I think it's $750
million a year it's bigger than the
Nobel fund that he donates and one day I
asked him I said what is the secret to
wealth and he looked at me paused this
big smile and his eyes got really bright
like they always did and he said Tony
it's what you teach I said well I teach
a lot of things you know which thing and
he said gratitude he said because you
and I Tony know billionaires that are
miserable and it's because they're not
grateful for what they have and we both
know people have no money seemingly but
they're so grateful for their health for
their husband for their wife for their
children they're so grateful to God
they're so grateful for their life that
they're rich you know so I think I think
it starts with that gratitude it starts
with that connection to Grace as
simplistic as that sounds and so it's
not enough just to have your financial
plan you have all the money and be
miserable let's have the money and be
really rich emotionally psychologically
disappointment either destroys you or
drives you and you have to decide which
one it's going to be if you don't
consciously decide there's always going
to be more BS for you to deal with and I
think but that's why I think you know
when I do my events the reason I do the
12 hours a day it's not cuz I like
talking it's just that I can tell you
something all day long or I can get you
to build the muscle and the build the
muscle is by experiencing it I always
tell people a belief a belief is a poor
substitute for an experience like I
could have a belief about you but I
experience you so I get to know who you
are right the same thing true is like
you have a belief about China you have a
belief about working out so I try to
give people experiences that are so
profound and then you know the the
studies they did they found people 12
months later 11 months later we're still
in the middle of Co they did my digital
seminar and you know they measured my
body like the amount of times I jump I
jump a thousand times in a day and I
weigh 282 lbs and I come down four times
the body weight so it's 1,000 lb times
1,000 lb of pressure I my lactic acid if
you've ever been with a friend and
you're running and you can't talk the
point you can't talk is a level four of
lactic acid I'm at an 18 still speaking
so they decided to do that on my
audience and they found an interesting
pattern this the same group that works
with some of the you know Super Bowl
champions and some of the Stanley Cup
champions and so forth there's a ratio
in the body of
testosterone versus cortisol the stress
hormone and when the ratio is balanced
they call it the championship bloodline
bloodstream it literally gets you to
follow through so when they did my
audience in my live seminar they found
that people literally mirror me all the
way through the experience that's
phenomenal biochemically that is
phenomenal but we did it on we did you
know cuz all of a sudden overnight they
said to me you know we're going to San
Francisco and the governor of California
says you we only have 10 people and we
have 15,000 so I was like We'll go to
Vegas they'll never shut down Vegas they
shut down Vegas I was like okay we'll
do, 1500 movie theaters with 10 people
in them they shut down the movie
theaters like okay we'll go to a church
in Houston I got a buddy I'll rent this
church for 15,000 people they're not
going to keep Costco open and shut down
the church they kept Costco open and
shut down the church so I finally said
okay I'm not going to do some crappy
little webinar so I get this Vision I'm
going to build this facility with 20
foot high LED screens 50 ft wide all
around me I'm going to call Eric Yan
Zoom I'm going to get them from a th000
up to 25,000 people so I can interact
with people live in real time on to
build an app so they can shake it and
the more people do it the louder it gets
so it's real so I built this whole thing
so now we're doing bigger events than
ever in our entire history but they did
the same measurements on them in
different parts of the world and saw the
exact same mirroring process and the
average person even digitally ever yeah
um 71% of the PE they had 71% drop in
negative emotions 53
per Improvement in positive emotions and
11 months later in the middle of covid
it held because it's a biochemical
change so when people say oh I'm trying
I read That's I write books because it's
it's an easy entry point to people
there's so much you can learn from a
book but there's nothing like the
experience that's why I do the events
and like the last two years because of
Co I did two like six day free events we
had 800,000 people attend for 6 days
just four weeks ago because I just
wanted people to have answers where they
are and then people start to see they
get momentum but it's hard to do just
reading something or watching a couple
of you know you know 20 minute or 15
minute or 5 minute little pieces on
YouTube those are great they might
inspire you but a transformation
requires immersion it's like if you ask
the average person did you study a
foreign language in school most people
oh yeah High School College speak it
they don't but if you turn around and
you said okay what if you want to learn
Italian and I just took you to Rome and
dumped you off for six week weeks yeah
with no teacher you're going to come
back 6 weeks later speaking you know
Italian so it's immersion and if you
want to master something I think that's
the thing most people don't do yes they
read a little bit they listen a bit they
dip in and out they don't go day and
night night and day in total immersion
in something that transforms them and
also something that makes them push
through their fears yes because in the
end that's the only thing that stops me
everybody's got a story I didn't know
this person I don't have the resources
they have all the things they don't have
but if you're resourceful you can get
the money you can get the time you can
get the energy you can get anything you
want and you got to get over your fear
to be resourceful so we do experiences
that are so physiologically profound
that those fears do not stop you anymore
and that's what that's how we get people
to get you know 10 years later they're
still transform from an experience that
was one weekend first of all if you're
concerned about covid according to CDC
and I have this in my new book the
number one you know issue besides age
obviously the number one piece is being
overweight right or obese that is number
one and just L week CNN New York Times
for the first time two years later are
coming at saying you can reduce your
risk if you take care of your body right
do you know what number two is according
to the CDC fear because when you get
fearful it changes your breathing your
body temperature your tension in your
body all these things can create a
trigger of reactions hormones in your
body that make you crazy so when I say
fear is physical here's what I mean you
fear is physical by the way so is
courage emotions are physical if you're
really scared if you ever been that
point where you're like freaked out
about something and you can't quite
fully swallow or you got that feeling in
your gut certainly but courage is also
physical that's what you're talking
about like it's like I trained myself
from a very young age at the number one
thing I had to do so I would follow
through on the things we're talking
about here is I had to have a mind and
body that were strong together that
every day I was going to do something to
strengthen my body even if it was just
10 minutes or 15 minutes something was
going to shift me physiologically to do
that and so I you know i' get scared or
I get frustrated I go on a run I go on a
Sprint and I wasn't in shape didn't
matter i' push myself beyond what I was
comfortable with I go lift weights and I
push beyond what I was comfortable with
and when you do that everything in your
nervous system changes because all of a
sudden when You Face something and you
push beyond the comfort zone you get
stronger and stronger even a little bit
each day changes things so think about a
courage that's not you're not afraid
because there' be no need for courage
courage is you're scared lless but you
do it anyway yeah and so training your
body and you and I both do this right we
train intensely because we know this is
the resource through which my mind is
going to try to make decisions and then
the second thing is every day you got to
feed your brain your mind because if you
don't crap is going in there
automatically we all know that right
yeah I mean today it's chasing you
because we all know the news knows
they're not bad people they're good
people they're just doing their job
their job is make sure they make as much
money for their shareholders and they
know one formula works and it's pretty
obvious these last two years more than
ever if it bleeds it leads if it
produces fear more people watch it's
because we all have a two million year
old brain
that's always looking for what's wrong
what can hurt us but your two milliony
old brain is not going to make you happy
right you have to take control of that 2
million year old brain and start to
direct consciously what you want your
life to be so changing your body
radically by a workout by a run by a
push by whatever you're going to do
shifting by feeding your brain every
single day and then making sure every
day you're taking some form of action
towards a compelling future like what am
I going to make better if you have
nothing to look forward to you're going
to be pissed off you're going to be
frustr at you're going to be depressed
you're going to be overwhelmed and in
those emotional states even though
you're a smart person and you know lots
of things you won't use anything you
know so to me the leverage to changing
somebody's life is always starting with
the human body if I started to speak to
you and I spoke more at uh this Tempo
and I said yeah I really think people
should get their act together and make
this their best year ever right I feel
terrible in my body now I'm not saying
everybody needs to talk fast or loud
like me that's my own physiology but
kind of trained but everyone has
different gears and when you're low
gears like you can be in a great
relationship somebody you totally love
and you're both in a great physical
state emotional state everything's great
you both get a little love from taking
the kids to 20 soccer practices and
Casual problems in the business and all
that stuff and all of a sudden Same Love
doesn't feel like the same love you
still love each other but it doesn't
come across and if you're both stressed
out then it creates problems in the
relationship so the most important
factor in your life is the ability to
manage your mental emotional state is
the one thing you have complete control
of once you learn how then it becomes
just the daily discipline and after it's
not even discipline it just becomes
Habit to say I'm not going to live in
this lousy Pace I'm not going to put up
with it I know what to do let me do it
let me move forward but that's why you
know I do programs and events where I
immerse people yeah because you know you
and I can talk about this a few minutes
kind of Nod your head but if I put you
in an experience correct tell people a
belief is a poor substitute for an
experience you can have a belief about
China I take you to China you're going
to have an experience it's very
different so true so I think human
beings need to put themselves more in
experiences there a lot of us today
especially with Co being stuck at home
and doing business from home a lot of
people are stuck in their head I tell
you get in your head you're dead you'll
just go in circles you got to get that
body and that energy moving and then
your head will start to work as well
there's so many ways that we Define
ourselves and identity is just the
culmination of the Bel beliefs you have
about who you are but those beliefs
control how you think how you feel what
you perceive how you interact with
people what you're willing to do not
willing to do the most powerful force in
the human personality is the need to
stay consistent with how we Define
ourselves and you know if you think of
someone who's having quote an identity
crisis what is that they turn a certain
age and they quickly question everything
they had accepted a belief is something
you feel absolutely certain about you
don't believe something if you start to
question it you produce doubt and so
sometimes there are certain stages of
life where someone suddenly goes out and
has this identity crisis and they buy a
sports car or whatever the case may be
and they change their hair and they do
everything else but what what's really
happening is they're trying to redefine
thems having defined thems a long time
ago and we all have these ways of
defining ourselves but let me an example
of just how powerful it is so I'll give
you a simplistic example I don't know if
you ever smoked cigarettes or know
someone who did but if you go to someone
smokes cigarettes and no longer does and
you said to them would you like a
cigarette they wouldn't say to you what
brand is it what would they say to you
no I'm not a smoker I'm not one of those
and that's really important because we
Define ourselves by what we are and by
what we're not and it's not effortful
when you're not a smoker it's not
effortful if you say I'm a health nut to
you know not smoke it's just not part of
your world you don't even consider it
because that need to stay consistent
with how you define yourself self is the
basis of a human being's basic
personality making decisions now the
downside of this of course is you can
create a negative identity for yourself
you can have an identity that says let's
say you've put things off a lot and you
know you're about to go do something and
then you get fearful everybody has the
fear of failure the fear of something of
the unknown and the last minute you
don't do it and then you say I'm really
going to do this and you do it again and
again after a while you don't want to
disappoint yourself so you might develop
a new identity and say I'm a
procrastinator well once that who you
are that behavior is going to be
consistent it is that powerful a control
system on how we function as human
beings so anything you attach the words
I am to over and over again consistency
with your language with your emotion and
with an emotional intensity you'll
eventually become it because it becomes
a belief and a belief is self-fulfilling
whether you think you can whether you
think you can't you're right so I think
this subject being able to differentiate
between having a certain feeling or act
a certain way and being that kind of
person is huge you can use this tool
when I'm working with somebody I'm
looking to create a lasting change I'm
looking to help that person shift how
they perceive who they are permanently
not just what they were doing one of the
most uh successful business people I
ever met when I was very young was a
multi-billionaire and I asked him you
know how he became a multi-billionaire
and he said to me and I shared it
earlier in this week so I don't know if
you heard it but he said proximity Is
Power you know if you look at uh
somebody like Bill Gates you know Bill
Gates quit Harvard and he you know
didn't have any software for this
company called Microsoft or the original
company he went to Altera and yet he
told him I'm going to go do this but the
real secret besides being very bright
and persistent was he had Direct
relationships at IBM to his parents they
on the board of directors and as you
connected with apple and started to
build a relationship then you had
proximity for someone to do it so my my
advice to you is number one stop caring
about how conservative or unconservative
there's some of the greatest different
radical types of music has come out of
Germany and Austria in the past hard
metal crazy stuff so while there is a
conservative culture there's a segment
that is extremely creative that comes up
with things no one else does in your
culture and so instead of finding the
limitations find the strengths or decide
what every great leader does create your
own culture right that's what a leader
does you know they don't look they don't
adapt to the culture you I'm sure you've
heard the old phrase that says you know
reasonably people people adapt to the
culture unreasonable people adapt the
culture to themselves that's why all
breakthroughs come from unreasonable
people I'm paraphrasing that's not the
right language but that's the essence of
it and so it's like you have to then
find within yourself that I have so much
passion so much certainty I'm going to
build that certainty and instead of
getting overwhelmed by all the things
you got to do you're to say let me just
make sure every day I'm making progress
every day I'm going to take a step
forward and I'm going to consistently
get in proximity with brilliant people
that are doing things in the direction
of what I want to do if I have to work
as a janitor which is what I did in the
beginning day and night while I was
still in school to get around people I
would be a janitor at this place where I
wanted to be around this executive and
quite honestly I'd read all his his uh
memos and things in the middle of the
night so I could think about how he
thought because I didn't have access
like I have today so get yourself in
proximity with people who are making
things happen and you and if you do a
great job at anything you do for them
when you work your guts out you'll
become a appreciated as you're
appreciated you become part of their
culture as you come to that culture
you'll get new insights and then
opportunities will happen and this
person by the way told me at one point
he said what do you want to accomplish
and I gave him some of my dreams and
goals and he said well those are big he
said how many you know private Equity
guys do you know how many people
investment bankers do you know and I
said no I don't know maybe a dozen he
goes how many you spend time with I said
none he said I want you to go and spend
time with them I said but I don't have
something to give I always have to give
something I get just my way I'm wired
right I don't and I don't know what I
really want yet or how to do it cuz it
doesn't matter they're going to want to
be around you get around them and I did
this for months and then suddenly one
day sure enough he said they're going to
want to do a deal with you and then
somebody brought me this deal and the
deal at the time you know made me about
$40 million in two months when I had
never made $4 million in a year working
20 hour days and then that deal fell
apart afterwards they wanted me to
change the deal and I learned from him
when somebody wants to to change the
deal don't get pissed think about what
you want and I put that in a new deal
where I made $400 million two years
later so proximity Is Power put yourself
in proximity keep your passion alive
keep making progress and make sure
you're trying to innovate or grow every
day in some way face your fears every
single day you'll find it'll change your
life lifestyle is not about
money it's about two
things creativity and
caring it doesn't take money it just
takes a little creativity to think about
those you love and think what would
light them up it will light you up more
than anything else I promise
you to surprise them to do beautiful
special things little
[Music]
things and makes people
feel important needed loved
appreciated what better way to
invest than invest in your relationships
with those you
love and you can't give joy to every
everybody else that you love without
giving joy to
yourself and then there's another kind
the other kind is where you invest in
those you don't even
know not for stars on your
chart cuz you know it's right it can be
done with such a small amount of money
it's not money it's creativity and
caring maybe it's animals that are
abused maybe it's old folks that people
don't pay attention to
anymore maybe it's providing one surger
for someone who has lost sight and can
see
again provide water for a family it's a
purpose larger than yourself that keeps
you going if it's only to meet your own
needs you will drop back into your
comfort zone but like you know for
example you know one of the great things
that came out of Co is I've spent most
of my life as a vagabond right because I
travel all over the Earth so in most
years I travel to you know 115 cities
and as you know most my seminars are
multi-day seminars and I go to 12 to 16
countries you know like Australia three
times and so all of a sudden Co hits and
I had to adapt I found this way to adapt
and now I'm reaching 10 times I'm you my
largest seminar is now 900,000 people
versus 15,000 I was trying I did one
football stadium in 2019 with 38,000
people 40,000 people it was incredible
now that's a tiny seminar you know cuz I
couldn't put 900,000 people in any
Stadium right so all this good comes
from that adaptation right figuring out
what to do but I think the other part of
it is you know during that same time one
of the great gifts was I could find a
way to be home and still touch people's
lives so deeply and do it in a way that
was impactful I could see it and feel it
and in their home I could see their
children I mean it's been amazing and
now I do both I do hybrid I got a
thousand people in front of me and 197
countries all around me but one of the
other benefits was is we'd want to have
a daughter and I told my wife I'm not
having a kid after 50 I don't want to
show up at high school reunion and be 70
years old but now I got I've got a n
I've got a 48-year-old daughter and a
9month old daughter to give you an idea
I got five kids of my grandads but my
daughter like all the things I've ever
done from myself biohacking and health
and all that stuff like now I'll be 80
at her High School reunion so like I I
got to use these things for a different
reason and so that doesn't let me get to
a certain level and stand there it's
like man I you know I got to be 92 to
102 range in order to do that I got to
know every tool in the toolbook to turn
it around so gave me even more drive and
then what comes out of that now is I can
help anybody I mean you know this is my
new book by the way it's called life
force it's coming out February the 8th
but you can pre-order it now on Amazon
or go to tony.com but the point is it's
like I wanted to know every single tool
I I got totally obsessed even more than
I normally am cuz it's like okay I got a
higher purpose I got all my grandkids
all my children but now I got my
daughter it's like I got to have these
tools dealing with the loss of someone
you care about is probably the most
difficult thing of all I would say maybe
uh as a child seeing the level of
frustration between my parents you know
I had four different fathers and
watching them kind of um you know accept
whatever life gave them as a it's why a
lot of my drive came about is seeing my
fathers be bered by my mother who I love
dearly um and just watching them break
down like you know probably the single
most painful event of my life but also
shaped me in such a beautiful way was
when I was 11 years old we had no money
for food and it was Thanksgiving which
in America is a you know big holiday
feast and so we'd been without food
before we'd have crackers and butter and
you know we survived but we weren't
going to have a Thanksgiving feast and
there's knock at the door and I go to
the door and there's this giant guy
there with groceries in each hand and he
had a pot beside him on the ground with
a uncooked turkey and I I just like I
said uh who are you here for he goes I'd
like to speak to your father and my mom
and dad were yelling at each other
saying things that you can never take
back and I'm trying to make make sure my
younger brother and sister they're five
and seven years younger wouldn't hear
any of this and that day changed my life
because I thought it was going to be the
most exciting Day Dad Dad go to the
front what is it I said it's for you you
answered no it's for you I remember we
open the door and I was just so excited
to see my father be happy like we're
going to have a feast this is going to
be incredible and he got angry and he's
like we don't accept charity he went to
slam the door and the man's face and the
man's foot was there so it bounced off
his foot he still open the groceries
he's like sir I'm just the delivery guy
he said it's it's not charity everybody
has a tough time someone bought this and
they're sending it to you as a gift and
my father said we don't take charity
goes to close the door again this time
the guy's shoulder was there also so it
bounced off again and then I was
standing right there and there's this
moment I'll never get where the this man
looked at my father and he looked at me
and he said sir don't let your ego make
your family uhh suffer and the veins on
my dad's face on on the side of his neck
I'll never forget they bull like his
face turned red I thought I was going to
punch him in the face and then there's
this moment my dad's shoulders dropped
he took the groceries slammed the door
didn't say thank you and stormed off and
I always remember thinking like how come
he's not happy you know you talk about
pain it's like I love my father so much
and he there's basically three decisions
that I think everybody makes in their
life that whether aware of it or not
moment to moment I figured this out
afterwards because I was so obsessed
with what's wrong because he eventually
left our family and that was the most
painful thing I ever had so it's like
feeling like I failed you know I blame
myself like why couldn't get through to
my father you know I was 11 years old
but later on it helped me understand the
three decisions are first you got to
decide what to focus on every moment of
your life there's something grabbing
your focus and you don't experience life
you experience the part of life you
focus on right what's wrong is always
available so is what's right right and
they're different kinds of focus and my
dad's Focus that day was really on what
he hadn't done and I know that cuz he
kept muttering it you I hadn't taken
care of his family there's no funy for
Thanksgiving somebody had to give us
charity and then the second decision you
make about once you focus on something
is what does it mean is this the end or
the beginning if you think it's the end
of a relationship you're going to behave
different than it's the beginning right
um my dad's meaning was that he was
worthless and so then the third decision
is what do I do which whatever meaning
come up creates the emotions which
affects what you do and what he decided
to do is leave our family but for me it
was like this is amazing I mean you know
we have having Thanksgiving you know
this is this is incredible we got food
what a concept and then the meaning
though is what changed my whole life
which was wow strangers
care that completely changed my life
that painful experience I couldn't deny
that somebody who wanted no credit
delivered this food to my family and so
what I decided to do is say someday I'm
going to do this for another family so
when I was 17 I had two families and it
was a euphoric experience I went and
jeans and a t-shirt I didn't go like the
delivery guy but I wanted to see the
face of the people and then next year
was four people and then it was eight
and literally my thing was doubling I a
little company and then I got to a
million people a year and I got to four
million people a year then I was doing
money Master of the game I'm
interviewing these billionaires Jay and
I'm watching Congress cut food stamps
it's now called the snap program by I
think it was $6 billion dollar so every
family that actually needs food and my
family was one of those back then they
all have to come up with a week's worth
of food out of every month so I was like
call my team and I said how many people
have I fed in my lifetime I didn't know
there was 42 million meals I was like
this pretty cool and I was like What if
I fed 50 million people like my entire
lifetime in one year and I was like what
if I did 100 Milli what if I fed a
billion people in 10 years so that was 7
years ago we're at 850 million meals
right and I'm going to hit the billion
earlier than what my promised and
targeted and then I've got a sustainable
approach but I tell you that because my
worst day was my best day MH my the most
painful day the day where I felt like I
do the least where I felt impotent led
me to have new understandings new skills
new capacities new drives new Hunger I
mean would I really be feeding 100
million people a year 100 million meals
a year if I was wellfed as a child
probably not you know I'd love to
believe I'm such a perfect person but no
I'm just I just know what suffering
feels like so I don't want anybody else
to suffer you know so I think sometimes
the suffering experiences of our life if
we don't let them crush us we let them
drive us they they actually become the
best day in your life and taking your
worst day and making your best day is a
beautiful Target for anybody for my life
like help people achieve accomplish
everything achieve make it happen and if
you ask me I was fulfilled I'd say of
course I was and I was I loved it but
there's different levels of fulfillment
right if you've never smelled a rose and
someone's telling you what a rose is
like you think you know to experience it
so I had this experience in India I go
about every two years and there was a
friend of mine there who's built this
amazing facility and he had like a
quarter million people showing up for
his event they expected they would have
you know I think they had 100,000 people
and a quarter million people showed up
and then a million two by the next
morning and the the guy that was there
is a really smart guy and so I had a
conversation with his son and he was
thanking me for all this work I've done
he goes tellon you of all the things
you've taught me he said I think maybe
the most important thing is all the ways
I can change my state I can get unstuck
I can I can get myself to follow through
he goes it is priceless and he really
thanked me and I said well I really
appreciate it and more importantly I'm
glad you're using it right he goes but I
just have one little thing I'd like to
ask you because you know you talk about
if you're in a peak State you get Peak
Performance or if you're in an energy
rich State a high energy State you're
going to produce differently than a low
energy state or a lousy State I said
yeah he goes well what if you call those
high energy states beautiful States I
said that's great because it's not just
happiness a beautiful state could be
excitement it could be gratitude it
could be love it could be kindness it
could be warmth it I mean there's a
million beautiful States it's any high
energy state where no one else to tell
you what to do you'll do the right thing
so he goes okay I said so we have
beautiful States great and then he goes
what if we took all those lousy States
those low energy states those those
types of states what we call those
suffering and Ed when he said that
probably kind of like what you
experienced it like nod at me a little
bit I like suffering I don't like
suffering I don't suffer but I do have
times when I'm frustrated or stressed or
overwhelmed so I couldn't deny it so I
was like okay yeah those would be
suffering States I felt this little trap
going on in me and I said why do you say
this yes he goes Tony because I think
it's the most important distinction
you've made but I like to use some other
words around it he goes because I've set
a spiritual vision for myself so what's
that
he said my goal is to live in a
beautiful state every day no matter what
he goes to me that would be the most
gorgeous life because you know people
have everything and they're miserable
they're pissed off they're frustrated
and so forth he goes you deal with them
all the time I said that is brilliant
but I change it slightly for me I'd say
life is too short to suffer go to me
that's where it starts Life's too short
to suffer how could I possibly suffer
when I've been able to live this
magnificent life it's just the mind if
you don't direct this thing it directs
you it's like you use the mind or it
uses you you use stress or stress uses
you and so I said you know okay so how
am I going to do that because it's one
thing to say it yeah it's not to develop
the habits yeah right and when I I found
myself like getting on a plane and you
know I have my own plane now obviously
but the time I used to go to Australia
four times a year and I'd fly on quantis
and when I moved to Florida it became 20
hours each way like a 40 hour trip for
one little visit yeah and I remember
getting on the plane and being so
stressed and I thought to myself Tony
how could you be stressed you're flying
in a plane you can fall asleep you can
you know it's not my size bed obviously
but I'm in first class and I'm very
lucky it's like come on what are you
what are you whining about in your head
and I realized what it was was that they
had no internet so now I'm flying for 40
hours and what's happening all my slacks
all my emails all my text all it's all
growing fortunately I got this resol in
my head before I got lucky enough to
have my own plane and I remember when I
got worked out I got on a plane I flew
from here to La I got on the plane LA
and the you know Captain comes on and
goes uh says Captain stubblebine it's
going to be a beautiful flight Sydney
and then he said something I never heard
before he said today I have a special
announcement and it's this we have for
the first time in the history of Quantas
International internet literally people
stood up on the plane and cheered and cl
I want to stand up too everybody see me
right so I stayed there and CRA in my
chair so we all open up our iPads our
our phones our everything we got right
we're all typing doing our stuff in
social media and N9 minutes later what
do you think happen it breaks down it
crashes when you think it turned on
again when you never never and the thing
that struck me at and it's changed my
life is I looked around me and people
were angry they were cursing what the
hell's wrong with this Airline they
can't get this right blah blah and I
looked around I was like this is amazing
9 minutes ago this was a miracle now
it's already an expectation gosh and
then I realized all the unhappiness
comes from all those expectations you
can't help have the Mind expect but you
can direct it and when you expect
something it's not met you get upset
yeah and it's like if if the only time
I'm happy is when everybody meets my
expectations I got 105 companies I got
3,800 employees on four continents what
are the chances someone screwing up
right now meaning doing something
different than I think they should 100%
so it's like I need to make it so that
other people don't have to behave a
certain way for me to be happy tired
just think of it this way if you got the
greatest computer in the world and you
plug it in there's not electricity it's
not going to work right well tired is
the first step to being depressed for
most people and most people are tired
not because they're working so hard like
oh man I worked so hard today what' you
do oh I had meeting after meeting you
know I sat in these meetings you know
and I talk to people or I make calls or
I send emails and they're like I'm
exhausted I mean what's happening is we
haven't pushed ourselves physiologically
for so long that we've gotten weaker and
weaker and so we feel tired from doing
nothing and so what you learn when you
go through a weekend like that is Holy
there is a level of energy on command
that's available to me that no one you'd
never believe but by being in the
environment over and over again you
learn it's real and you learn to use it
and when there's enough energy anything
everything else works better your
relationship is not going to be great no
matter what tools you have if you're
tired because you're going to go love
you love you you know there's no there's
no aliveness right you're not going to
grow your business when you're tired so
a huge part of what I teach even in
Unleash the Power Within ubw by the way
for people not V it's called Unleash the
Power Within it's a weekend and on the
fourth day it's all energy it's all
about the things you do with your health
and vitality so you sustain that because
without that nothing else really matters
and there was this man I'll never forget
who came and he took half the stuff he
gave and he gave it to somebody else and
he kept handing out food for everybody
else cuz he got into the whole Spirit of
you saw his whole again he became some
not looking for help you someone who
could be giving help it's an identity
change all lasting change by the way in
your life my life for anybody's is a
change in identity anything else is a
fight it's like if you ever you know if
you once smoked and you don't anymore
and I came to you and said would you
like a cigarette you're not going to go
what brand is it you're going to say I'm
not a smoker I'm not one of those
identity is the most powerful force that
controls the human psyche change your
identity change your life expand your
identity expand your life shrink your
identity shrink your life so I try to
get people to do things that change
their identity even even silly fun
things we do like the firewalk or wood
bre things that we do are give someone
an experience that after they do it
their brain says if I can do this what
else can I get myself to do that's the
way that I think you create a real
lasting change with people what you have
to look at today is number one you got
to invest in yourself just like we
talked about earlier you got to make you
more skilled and more powerful and more
effective so that you can command more
going forward economically so whether
there's inflation or not it doesn't
affect you and because there's going to
be inflation for probably a period of
time here we're going to see a tough
environment the second thing is to keep
feeding your mind and your emotions so
that you don't freak out like everybody
else then the third thing is you do have
to get in the game you know it's like
the first thing you should do is stop
being a consumer and become an owner I
mean you and I both know that's not what
most people are if you own an Apple
phone and you don't own Apple that's a
giant mistake I'm not saying Apple this
price or that price it's just over time
if you're a consumer you lose the secret
to living is giving cuz you're never
going to be happy by what you get you'll
get it you'll be excited for a while for
how long but if you keep giving you'll
become something unique that whether
other people know it or not you will
know who you are people can take away
all your things they can't take away who
you become as a man or as a woman as a
soul so business is a spiritual game how
can I do more for others than anybody
else how can I do it consistently how
can I do it better how can I fall in
love with my clients and just overd
deliver levels they can't even imagine
and develop this beautiful relationship
of such Joy it isn't a transaction there
are transactions involved but you're not
doing it for the transaction you're
doing it to make that difference in
their business or their life when you're
driven by a mission more than yourself
you get a level of energy that people
just try to take ofs will never have so
my heartfelt wish for you my dear
friends is remember what business is
it's a spiritual game it's about what
can you give not what can you give
you'll get
plenty if you'll give much more than you
expect to receive if you do that you'll
have more than
money you have a life of incredible
meaning and your life will be blessed
you know I stayed in a relationship for
20 years where I was really not happy I
made everybody else happy which was my
whole sacrifice thing sacrifice thing
and um and the reason I did it was
because I grew up with four fathers
right I swore I'd never get a divorce so
you know you build these ideals I
remember there's certain things like I'd
rather die than that oh what a stupid
thing to say but we develop these
beliefs that once they become an ideal
they kind of have they possess you and
they take you over so you got to be able
to question anything and so the answer
to your question is yes there's a time
to move on there's a time to start
something new there's a time to learn
the lesson that this business or this
relationship or this experience has
given you and make a move because
otherwise the real test is are you
growing like if you're in a relationship
you know it's a great relationship if
you're constantly wanting to be better
for the person you love if you don't
really give a [__] what they think
that's not a good sign right right I
mean it just means there there's not the
level of in of intimacy there's not the
level of connection you might have been
together forever but it's not where it
needs to be so it's like telling
yourself the truth I think is the
hardest thing for people and I think the
ideals get in the way of that truth
meaning the things you've you know and
grandis in your mind to be absolute but
I think when it comes to a business bus
it's not an easy question when it comes
to an investment I don't Investments
it's easy I don't move to a new
investment till I found a better one I
don't just get pulled by the next shiny
thing I really look and make sure it's
there when it comes to businesses I'm
pretty crazy I've stayed in businesses
way too long I should have probably
gotten out but I did it and then sold it
and made a little money it just it was
my whole thing that I don't quit so but
I think there are times when you have to
adapt the business to something new I
mean if I was still doing what I was
doing two years ago you know on the road
doing what I was doing I mean I would do
115 cities on average um usually 12 to
16 countries as on a train of plane
helicopter every two to three days and I
I don't even and no one would have ever
stopped me because they couldn't because
there's so much momentum of what I'm
doing but if I was doing that right now
you know my 250 employees at that
company would be all unemployed you know
because all around the world they made
it illegal to do what I was doing so you
have to be able to tell yourself the
truth about where you are and also
though not give up too easily by saying
where's the season of this business okay
where's the development like if a
business is really young it's a toddler
business it's going to burn more cash
then it's going to give you back if it's
a you know if it's a business that's in
that go- go phase that teenage phase you
get overconfident grows like crazy and
then you don't have the profits at some
point when the sales slow down and you
got real trouble is it a business that's
aging but also I gota look at what's the
industry like I'll give an example I
have a friend really good guy maybe
44 45 years old Prime of his life Like
You Ed really well put together I mean
takes care of his body great mind great
mindset without giving his personal life
away he owns a a very large business in
Australia dominates an industry and the
industry relates to big box office
supplies okay so I had him at one of my
business seminars and I'm walking him
through these stages just like a human
being goes through life stages so does a
business just like history right yes and
if you know what stage you're in you
know you can do the right thing at the
wrong time and you don't get rewarded
yes plant in the winter you don't get
rewarded right buy a house sounds good
2007 maybe not the best time right you
know so it's like you got to take a look
at where these things fit where where is
the where is the real decision- making
here that makes this happen so anyway
he's got this off supply business and
he's young and dynamic so in his life
cycle he's in his prime yeah his
business is in its prime he's worked for
years it's crushing it but where's the
industry is that a young business a
growing business yeah an aging business
there's no question it's an aging
business and I said to him I said you
got to separate these out because if
you're using your brain intelligently
you got to sell this business because
even though you got a great business the
multiple is going to go down every year
because the industry is going down yes
take those resources and reinvest so
again it's looking at things by telling
yourself the truth seeing what stage
they're in and seeing what stage the
world's in you might have the best idea
in the world but it's not going to work
when everybody shed in their homes
perhaps depending on what the product or
service is so you have to that to me a
breakr is a moment in time it's a moment
when the impossible becomes possible and
you don't just think about it but you
act upon it you know it's like you can
have a concept that doesn't create a
breakthrough the Breakthrough is when
you get to the point where you actually
going to do something about it and I ask
people all the time I ask your listeners
or viewers as well it's like I'm sure
you've had a time where you struggle
with something right you're going to do
something about this relationship but
you keep not changing it right you know
pulling back or you're going to stop
smoking or you're going to go lose those
25 lounds or whatever it is and you
start to make progress and then you pull
back and you get disappointed and get
frustrated but then there's sometimes
where finally you hit this threshold you
hit this moment where your brain says
not in another day not in an hour I'm
changing this relationship I'm losing
this weight I'm making this happen and
people create that breakthrough and it
can be happen you know it's a difference
between what triggers it versus what
makes it possible what triggers it is
usually pain or massive inspiration
nothing in between does it most people
they hit a threshold of pain and say
it's like you know I ask people how many
of you ever been in a relationship way
too long and everybody raises their hand
I go why why'd you stay you weren't
happy they weren't happy it's just
because of the unknown the uncertainties
the the idea of change it could be worse
you know to be alone but then there's
that moment when you finally hit the
threshold you go it's been painful in
the past it's painful now it's going be
painful future I'm going to change it
now so the trigger that finally made
that happen I'd ask your audience if
they think of something where they
finally broke through what was the
trigger usually that moment that day you
hit a threshold of I can't take anymore
I'm changing or something inspired you
you saw some was possibly if they can do
it I can do it as well but that's what
makes it possible what makes it last is
a change in your emotions or a change in
your belief system or a new strategy
right you and I both know because you're
both strategists the right strategy hell
you can consume a book and remember more
of it in 30 or 45 minutes than you did
when you used to spend 10 days on the
damn book right you know it's the right
strategy but you're not going to find
the strategy until it's a must for you
not a should you know what I mean or
it's that change in belief it's like
okay I've put up with this crap long
enough I'm better than this there's
something more in me that you finally
finding yourself or you finally get
pissed off enough or you get excited
enough to make that real change and so
what I've studied is I like to take
complex things and make them simple
because I found that you know the more
you know when I was really young I tried
to make things more complex I think to
try to convince myself how smart I was
or other people I don't know what but
it's stupid cuz complexity is the enemy
of execution and the only way your life
changes or your business changes is
execution so it's like how do you make
it simple and I started looking at all
these you know I've been doing this this
my 45th year doing this I started when I
was two of course and and I started
seeing these patterns all over the world
working with a greatest people on Earth
athletes business people the most
challenged people in prisons like what
are the common denominators in all these
cultures and I began to see there's
three things you need for a breakthrough
but most of us do them in reverse order
so we don't get the Breakthrough the
number one thing most people do when
they want to have a breakthrough they
don't they want to change their body
want to change their Finance they look
for a strap which makes common sense
that's what I used to do but the problem
is strategy could be the problem and
maybe you need a better strategy but
that's not usually the real problem
right like for example 34 of America is
overweight or obese if we're the fattest
humans in the history of the world we
all know covid other than age the number
one risk factor is obesity that's number
one and yet very few people do anything
about it and why is that is it because
you know the strategy for being fit and
strong is so complex or only the 1% know
it or it costs a fortune to do it no you
have to be fighting not to see all the
strategies to make your body physically
better they're around you everywhere so
it's you could have the wrong strategy
like I remember years ago on the cover
of Time Magazine they had the Atkins
diet and they said you know I think it
was 15% of Americans were doing it well
if you got to pee on a stick so you
don't get too acidic and your breath is
that bad it's pretty obvious that's not
sustainable so sometimes it's a strategy
problem but when you work for the how
first and you've never figured it out
your emotions get in the way it's the
wrong sequence it's like the dog bit
Johnny Johnny bit the dog same words
different experience of your Johnny so
strategy naturally is where people go
but rarely do they change with that what
the real problem usually is the story
they've developed and a story is just a
code for all the things you told
yourself over and over over again till
you believe them right there's an old
language pattern that says tell Li big
enough loud enough long enough sooner or
later people believe it that was Hitler
said that and so most of us are Hitler
in our own mind so it's not that they
can't you know what what do people say
how come I can't lose BL I can't lose
weight because you know I've tried
everything no if you tried everything
you'd be fit right they didn't try
everything I've tried millions of things
really name them well I've tried
hundreds to name them and then they'll
tell you three stupid things that don't
work that they did over and over again
right so it's the story I I I don't have
a relationship cuz all the good ones are
gone or they're gay and I'm not or I'm
gay and they're not or whatever the
story is the story is what'll keep you
like I'm sure you know Jim you've have
so many great strategies you share with
people haven't you had times when you
give someone an answer right there in
front of them and they just can't even
see it right they don't believe it cuz
the story is literally blinding them in
Psychology we call a skuta a blind spot
but then there's one level deeper than
even the story and that's your state the
mental emotional physical state you're
in because when you're in a low mental
emotional physical state you can have
all the brain capacity in the world but
you're not going to use it and so when
you're in a lousy State you come up with
a lousy story and then no strategy works
it doesn't matter what it is if I don't
know if you've ever noticed if you ever
gotten really angry at somebody and then
suddenly you remember all the ways
they've ever screwed you over you've
been upset with them right but but on
the other hand you fall in love and
what's wrong with life nothing I have no
money it doesn't matter we're in love
it's all wonderful right so the sequence
in which we do things accelerates or
decelerates or stops progress when it
comes to a breakthrough and what I found
is change the state first if you like we
can you and I can talk and give people a
million strategies but if I'm sitting
here at home in this state and I'm just
listening like this and nodding like
this yeah that makes nothing's going to
happen so the Reon reason that I've done
events over my lifetime and the reason
why I do immersion events you know know
10 12 14 hours a day you learn a little
bit at a time like language you don't
remember the language a few years later
but I drop you in Rome and say you got
no teacher and you got 60 days I'll be
picking you up I'll pick you up 60 days
an hour you're going to be speaking
Italian right especially if I put you
maybe with some passionate people who
are really going for it in their life
you're going to have a whole different
state about you you're going to develop
a new story and you're going to figure
out the strategy so I think the the
challenge for most people especially
with covid is we've all had our state
dropped people have been isolated
they've been pushed at home they've had
expectations that have fallen away like
I remember a year ago a lot of people
are like all right we got vaccines now
it's a new year it's going to be a brand
new thing you know
2021 now this year you talk about people
don't even have any goals or anything
because they've gone into learned
helplessness because they've been
disappointed so many times they start
thinking the problem is forever no
problem is forever no war is forever no
pandemic is forever your your mind is
weak now and it's gotten weak habits and
you're in a lowered state so you start
to believe that and so it's like you got
to change people's State first then you
got to give them the story that can help
them then you give them the strategies
that work and there even if you don't
give them the strategy they'll figure
out their own strategy you're a perfect
example of that right you figured it out
because you got yourself to the point
where it's like I've got to turn this
around and then you have something that
you can give and that expands your life
as you've experienced Jim uh right now
you know out of covid so many people
have been shut down in terrible place
and you know I'm sure you've seen that
drug overdoses are the largest they've
ever been in history was over 100,000
people last year suicides one out of
four kids under the age of 30 according
to the CDC whether they're accur or not
I don't know have considered suicide
sometime in the last two years because
we all need a compelling future we need
to look something to look forward to so
Stanford came to me and the their
genetics lab has been doing research on
depression and what they found was that
on by doing meta studies is only 40% of
the people who go in for therapy who
they get drugs and therapy together
usually only 40% make any Improvement
60% don't improve at all that's not a
lot more than what you can get on some
placebos MH and so uh they approached me
and said a couple of people went through
one of your programs one was clinically
depressed they're not anymore but we
don't have any science on this would you
be one of us do a science test I said
sure So they came out to this state with
Destiny seminar I do which helps people
to change their values and belief
structures I don't tell them what they
need to be but they figure out what it
needs to be and it changes the way you
perceive life the way you experience
life how you feel what you do it's a
rewiring of your model of the world
basically in six days and so they said
we're going to model this after the
greatest breakthrough they found in
science that no one able to follow up on
they about two years ago John's Hopkins
did a study on depression and they gave
people psilocybin right which comes from
magic mushrooms
and they did therapy for 30 days and at
the end of it 53% of the people were
depression free 30 days later never
happened like when we say 40% are helped
the average amount of help is 50% less
depressed right that's what the average
is some people completely turn around
some people don't all in this one 53% of
the people so it's four times the result
of any drug that ever been done but
unfortunately Soul C's not legal so
they're still working on that and they
said we're going to copy that exact
study and we're going to have a a group
that they compared to which is didn't go
to the seminar the comparison group is
going to do gratitude journaling and so
forth because positive psychology talks
about that and they said that's probably
what this seminar does is just positive
thinking well the cool thing was when
they came out the results were so
amazing at Stanford that they went and
had two new additional double blind
people do the research because it just
seemed so ridiculous at the end of oh
the first week 63% of people had no had
no depression symptoms at the end of 6
weeks it increased Due Time 100% of the
people had no no depression symptoms 19%
of the people had uh suicidal ideation
zero had suicidal ideation it blows away
any study it just came out it's coming
out next week in the psychiatric Journal
which is Journal amical medic
Association psychiatric Journal are the
two top journals in the field they can't
even believe it so they're going to do
more and there the the actual scientific
article says this is more powerful than
any drug therapy or any forms of normal
therapy combined and what are we doing
we're getting people to change basically
those three questions to some extent
because your values control what you
focus on if you're security driven and
you're here down in my basement right
now you're like where where's the exit
right you came down a slide like how do
I get out of here right if you're
Adventure driven you don't care you
don't even know where it is so your
focus is controlled by your values and
your belief systems right the meaning of
things is controlled by your belief
systems so those three decision-making
things you know what I'm going to focus
on what does it mean what I'm going to
do shift and one good example this Jay
is maybe your audience can relate to
this if we just took three patterns so
let's say Focus most people have a focus
either on what they have or what's
missing we both we all do both but what
do you think most people focus on more
often what they have or what's missing
what's missing that's right now even
Achievers do that like it's not like
somebody who's not successful it's one
of the reasons you see these Achievers
that no matter what they do it's never
enough because think about it if you're
always focusing what's missing from your
life how can you sustain happiness it's
software that will not allow that you'll
feel happy for a little moment then you
notice it's missing again um what do you
think's more often people focus on what
they can control or can't control well
they can't control yeah in my seminars
it's can control that's why they go I
want to learn how to take control of my
body or my finances or my business
whatever it is so it's the opposite but
the average person it's what they can't
control and with covid there's so much
you can't control around you that people
really sunk in that well how's someone
going to feel just everyone think about
it if you're constantly focused on
what's missing from your life and what
you can't control and then I'll add one
more do you focus more on the past the
present or the future we all do all
three but we tend to have one we focus
more on where do you think more people
focus past that's right and Achievers
focus on the future and happy people on
the present I think most people who are
driven have drive already it's really
about directing that drive it's really
about strategy um but I do believe in
passion I do believe in energy because
without high levels energy you don't do
anything anything um but most of my
focus is really how increase the quality
of life for people and I've basically
spent my life studying who are the most
successful people on Earth in various
areas your body your emotion your
relationship your finances you know your
business and I've tried to apply those
things to myself first to prove they
work to me and then I've been able to
take them to tens of millions and
hundreds of millions of people through
events and programs and I love to do it
in a way that actually creates change
you know Harvard did a excuse me
Stanford did a study they came to me
during Co
because as you know uh you know people
of depression shot through the roof as
people were shut down we've had the
largest number of people overdose on
drugs in our entire history of the
country and you know if you go
traditionally to deal with depression
how do you do it well you maybe go to a
therapist and they work very hard to
help you and more than likely they give
you a medication and you know Across The
Meta studies they explained for me at
Stanford that only about 40% of people
actually are helped 60% after a year
have not improved at all the 40% that do
improve if you go across all the meta
studies their average Improvement is
about 50% they're half as depressed as
they were now some people are totally
cured and some people not at all of
course but it's pretty pathetic when you
think about it because placebos can
almost have that impact and so they came
to me and they said you know Tony they
some of the people from the Stanford
genetics lab actually attended My Date
With Destiny seminar it's a Six-Day
total imersion program where you
basically find how your brain creates
meaning how you value things how how to
shift that and they were radically
shifted one was very depressed so they
said there's no real data would you be
aing to do a study on how using no drugs
what kind of impact we could find so
they took a group of people and they
they did a a group they modeled the the
most successful study ever Dan was done
recently two years ago I think it was at
John Hopkins they used psilocybin which
is basically magic mushrooms and and
therapy for a month and they produced
result unlike anything you've ever seen
53% of the people after 30 days were no
longer no symptoms whatsoever being
depressed which it's like four times
more than you would normally see and so
um but unfortunately it's an illegal
drug and they're still trying to figure
out how to utilize it so they wanted to
use this event so they put one group and
they mirrored them they had a group do
positive journaling from Stanford and
they end the group that went through the
seminar and about 177% had um tic um
focus on suicide the rest were depressed
clinically depressed and after 30 days
this is the part they couldn't believe
they literally uh double blinded this
twice by two other organizations CU they
just couldn't believe it 100% of the
people were absolutely free of any
symptoms and none of them tic Suicidal
Thoughts at the end of 30 days then they
did a study following people 11 months
later from the general population who
went to one of my programs digitally for
four days just a weekends called Al the
power then and they found 70% reduction
in negative emotions 52% increase in
positive emotions 48% drop in anxiety
but 11 months later they still had the
same numbers and it was still Co that's
why they 11 versus 12 months so there
are tools out there that can make a
difference and so to think that's
motivation certainly knowing what drives
you is important if you're overweight
what drives you is food right you know
let's be honest everyone's driven the
question is about what are you driven to
relax are you driven to change the world
are you driven to get healthy and so my
focus has really been finding those
strategies and I'm really excited I've
been doing this for this is my you know
45th year doing this I started when I
was 17 believe it or not I'm 62 and I've
seen just about than you can imagine in
195 countries working with people and
you discover that it's just patterns
like you have extraordinary patterns not
blowing smoke you and I are good friends
but I was blown away by you as a man not
only as a leader but as a human being
why is it that we often wait to
experience pain before we decide to
change a part of our Lives make a
different choice to create a shift why
is it that we wait so often for stress
and pressure I had that question was
burning in me cuz you know I was
traveling around have the privilege of
this stage of life you know traveling
around the earth working with people
from every Walk of Life right 100 plus
countries I've worked in and I'd see the
same problems even though You' me in
different cultures like you know go to
an Asian culture it's not about the
individual it's about the group right
but I'd still see the same problems and
then I got obsessed with it like okay
what what's the common Human Experience
because I'm seeing the same problems
even though it's a different culture
even though it's different beliefs right
and I began to realize that there are
certain human needs and there were six
that I identified that I've used ever
since and it's helped me understand and
so one of those needs needs a certainty
and it's the base human need certainty
that you can avoid pain and that you can
be comfortable is the most basic need
it's a survival need because if you have
continuous pain that's continuous damage
continuous damage equals Death right but
what happens for people is most people
that first basic need is where they live
they don't grow another need the second
need is uncertainty because ironically
if you're certain all the time you're
bored out of your mind if you're
completely uncertain you're kind of
freaked out and a balance is not it it's
the ability to use both enter both
worlds and then there's the need for
significance which is a big part of our
culture today thanks to social media um
that need to feel special unique
important right it can be very positive
emotion or need it can be very negative
depending upon how it's used how it's
directed and then there's the need for
connection and love which everybody has
and those four needs everybody finds a
way to meet if if you have to lie to
yourself work 20 hour days you're going
to find certainty somehow you're going
to find variety you're going to find
some form of significance some people do
it by tearing other people down some
people do it by working harder you know
it's different you're going to find some
level of at least connection if not love
but the final two what make people feel
alive which is growing everything in the
universe grows or dies and contributing
everything in the universe contributes
or it's eventually eliminated by
Evolution so those are the spiritual
needs growth and contribution where you
get Beyond yourself and I think that the
majority of us don't take moves because
of fear and fear is just uncertainty
it's that base need if when I go around
and I describe this in more detail and I
work with a big audience 15 20,000
people and I'll say how do a set of
exercises and them figure out where do
they get what triggers them to be
certain or uncertain what triggers them
to have variety and so forth so they
understand that like everything I do is
to meet these needs but then I get them
to say what are your top two not what
you think they should be not what you
want them to be what are they and 90% of
the people in our culture are certainty
and significance are significance and
certainty even though they really want
love so they have this route like if I
can be successful enough then I'll be
worthy of it or if I can just control it
enough and know it's that way but you
can't control love right right and so
most people are they're trying to meet
their needs in a kind of a backwards way
and I think that that fear that
uncertainty is what keeps most people
from growing until they get enough pain
and then that pushes them through a
threshold where their needs aren't being
met they got to change and unfortunately
most people wait till they have enough
pain now I that's not my preference your
happiness will never last as long as
it's got expectation behind it don't get
me wrong I have businesses I run them we
manage them but I know that people are
going to screw up or my idea screw up is
different than I think they should be
and sometimes their screw up will turn
into something even better right I got
to give it room so what I did was I
began to
realize I made the decision it's the
most important decision I believe of
your life that I'm not going to suffer
anymore Life's too short to suffer and
I'm going to live in a beautiful state
every day and the way I do it is I catch
myself and I start to get that sense of
stress I let it go and I see the ID go
by so your thoughts thoughts about this
person messing up your business or not
falling through if I was in a room with
10,000 people I guarantee you 60 70% of
the business owners have the same
thoughts at times right I ask people all
the time tell me your most stressful
thought oh I'm worried about my children
this may happen how many of you have had
that thought everybody uh I might not
make it financially love how many you
had that everybody my point is it's not
your thought it's the mind not your mind
when you think it's your mind you
identify with it and it's you can't
separate from yourself right but when
you realize these thoughts been around
for millions of years and I'm just
thinking the same thought that so many
people thought before like how many
people have ever thought I'm going to
kill the son of a now you didn't do it
you didn't believe you're really going
to kill them but you felt it you said it
you were there right so we all have
thoughts it's only the stressful
thoughts we believe that mess us up so
what I try to show people is if you can
start to realize these thoughts have
been around for millions of years if I
told you a million you know thousand
hundred years ago that we're going to go
to the moon and back you called me a
lunatic or crazy if I said 100 years ago
you're going to have a little box like
this it'll fit in your pocket and you
can click on it and you can see what the
weather is any place you can click on it
and see a live person on the other side
of the earth and talk to them by looking
this box and the way it works is
invisible waves are traveling around the
earth and it pulls invisible waves in
the Box you go like read between the
lines there's no way you dumb idiot it's
never going to happen so what I want you
to realize is thoughts are invisible
waves when you turn on a TV it takes
invisible wave
and depending on the channel you're
going to see a love story or an
adventure or a drama or a comedy or
horror the way you use your body
determines which of those thought waves
come through you one moment you're
pissed off the next moment somebody
makes you laugh you change your body you
change the channel you change what comes
through you so what I've tried to do in
this area beautiful state is simple yeah
first identify where you're suffering
what's your favorite flavor are you a
worrier are you a pissed off person
stressed angry is that you do second of
all decide you're going to kill that
monster while it's little you're not
going to wait till it's Godzilla taking
the city you're going to break the
pattern you start to feel the stress you
see it as thoughts going by and then you
focus on something to appreciate andjoy
or love appreciation love and joy
destroy suffering you can't be grateful
and angry simultaneously it's possible
you can't be worried and fearful and and
grateful simultaneously so I tell people
gratitude is one of the emotions to
cultivate that'll destroy the suffering
that's what we teach people to do where
focus goes energy flows most people are
focused on what they're afraid of and so
more fear comes their way and it's easy
because we all have a two million year
old brain that's designed to look for
what's wrong to protect so we protect
ourselves to fight it or to run for it
or to freeze right that's the way our
old brain is wired it's a two million
year old brain but that brain's never
going to make you happy you have to
learn to take control of your focus and
if you focus on oh my God it's never
going to work or you listen to somebody
who tells you oh you know CO's going to
be here forever we're never going to
have any freedom again and you focus on
that you can get really depressed as
most people have we've had 100,000
people overdosed on drugs we have more
depression and more people in a suicidal
mode than we've ever seen in the last
two years because people need a
compelling future you can deal with a
tough today if you got a compelling
tomorrow and so what I help people do is
design that but once you change your
focus you'll change how you feel focus
and feeling go together I just hate to
see people limit I hate to see people
suffering suffering I suffered enough
myself I don't want anybody else to
suffer and I I'm lit up by being able to
see people readly take control of their
life and we can't control everything
obviously there are things beyond our
control but there's so much within our
control that people give up because
they're afraid or they don't want to
fail or they're just pissed off or
frustrated overwhelmed or stressed and
so uh what I've managed to do is to take
fundamental principles that can change
the way you think and the way you feel
and the way you behave your finances
your body your emotions your
relationships I've been obsessed for
principles that can make that happen but
I'm pretty good at creating an
environment where I create a community
very quickly where 10 20 30 40 50,000
people in in a room for 3 or 4 days with
me you know people who wouldn't sit for
a three-hour movie because you know
someone spent $300 million on it and
you've been there I have 15 20,000
people there for 50 hours in a weekend
and nobody leaves they can vote with
their feet and they get their money back
anytime they want they don't it's a
stadium full of people who become alive
in their different religions different
backgrounds different belief systems
different sexual preferences different
political views and yet we come together
for a high are good and to me that's the
most extraordinary experience but
there's an energy to it also because
ideas when people say knowledge is power
it's it's a lie knowledge is not power
it's potential power you know execution
trumps knowledge every day of the week
and my job is to get people execute when
you get people execut they get momentum
and when they get momentum it's
self-fulfilling right okay I know who I
am now I know what I'm capable of and
you tend to go to higher and higher
levels of contribution of impact and
success I looked for who are the people
producing the greatest results not who
can talk a good game who's producing the
result a lot of people can talk about it
it's interesting I'm a results guy and I
believe in modeling my original teacher
was a man named Jim ran you've probably
heard of and he used to always say
success leaves Clues if you want
something make it a study immerse
yourself so when I wrote money Master
the game I said okay I've been coaching
Paul tutor Jones one of the top 10
Traders for 25 years I know more than
most people ever know in a lifetime but
I want to know it all so I'm going to
interview 50 of the smartest Financial
people on Earth Ray do icon i Warren
Buffett I want to interview people that
started with nothing and became
multi-billionaires and they're all
different but my whole belief is you
look for there's like three skill sets
that we all should have if we're great
and you're really good at these gy I'm
not throwing smoke your way it's just
the truth what's made you great what
makes me great what made you know what
made you know everything take off for
any type of business or life is
understanding pattern recognition if you
understand pattern recognition you know
what to do with Finance if you
what do in business if you're great at
pattern recognition with music you can
do an amazing job if you're good at
pattern recognition with dancing you can
move your body in ways most people never
dream of the people that become Masters
at pattern recognition but then pattern
utilization they recognize the pattern
but then they use it those are the
people that have extraordinary lives and
then there is one third level and that
is pattern creation where you literally
start you played other people's music so
much and now you know enough that now
you're able to create your way of doing
things I think those three skill sets
are there so my process is who's the
best in the world on Earth and how to
get access to them and at this stage of
my life that's not that difficult to do
but even with the money book I knew some
of them but then I'd say listen I I get
four or five people I knew to were to
refer me and I'd say give me 30 minutes
my average interview was three and a
half hours I remember Jack ble who's now
passed away who created Vanguard saying
I invited Tony Robbins into my house for
30 minutes and three and a half year
hours later I had the most probing
interview of my entire their career um
because you know I'm pulling those tools
out and once they saw the level I was
playing the game at then they wanted to
help and that's you know now Ray Doo is
a good friend of mine so the people I
have access to that I can pitch and
catch with because I immerse myself and
because I learned from all the people
around them it gave me a greater base so
that's what I chew with anything but
then I try to take that complexity like
Finance with all these people and all
the different approaches some are macro
Traders you know some are value Traders
Etc and say what are the common
denominators how do I simplify that so
we can actually use it so you can follow
through and that's my process it's one
of things I'm behind I have about a
dozen really important things to me
feeding people's most important to me
providing fresh water I do that in India
for quarter a million people a day
personally I'm going to get that to a
million people the next few years about
infrastructure uh freeing you know boys
and girls women or about 80% of them I
mean there's a new child abducted every
30 seconds there's 6 million people in
slavery around the world children in
slavery sexual slavery uh We've saved
about 3,800 just in the last couple of
years I've gone on the operations myself
undercover and but what I work with
Underground Railroad because they're
former Seal Team 6 CIA FBI and we teach
the local government what to do to
capture these people so it's not just
all save some kids right now but showing
them what to do for the future um but
I'm also you know I'm involved with so
many different things and my answer is
if I think it's it's core to humanity
then I'm interested food is air is you
know I've planted 10 million trees in
the last year and a half you know I'm
fortunately have my own private jet but
I'm conscious of that so it's like how
many trees does my whole lifestyle take
it's about 3,000 trees I said I don't
plant you know 10 million I said screw
it I plant 100 million so I planted 10
million already I'm on course to do the
100 million just like feeding a billion
people so it's it's the things that
matter that's what gotes me but I do
things spontaneously I was in San
Francisco and I read in the newspaper
that while I'm there there to see Mark
Ben off and I see that the the the
toughest part of San Francisco is called
the tenderloin district and there's
these nuns there that feed the poorest
of the poor and they're being evicted
and you know it's the richest one of the
richest cities in the world more
billionaires there Tech billionaires
than anyone no one's doing anything so I
just I went over knocked on the door
introduced myself found out who the
person was who was you evicting him
called him up and said look I'm a I'm an
owner too you have the right to evict
anybody but you really want to be the
hatest man hated his man in San
Francisco I said why don't you let him
stay nine months I'll get him out within
nine months I'll pay you the additional
rent and I did and then you know the
nuns like they're looking for a place to
lease and all of a sudden I get a call
from the realt TR because they're
looking for a place to buy and I called
the nuns and said you know some money I
don't know about the God will provide as
they stare at me so I bought him I
bought him a place there you know and
then and my friend Mark Benny off and
bought them a home just to live in so
you know I I do things spontaneously I
love those things as well but I mean
Life The Secret of living is giving I
know that sounds corny but I a tough
time in my life I remember I was driving
on the street in this 1968 Volkswagen I
was working so hard and I was so
frustrated things weren't going the way
I thought they should and I was like
what's wrong and then I pulled over the
side and I still have today this written
Journal WR the secret deliv giving is
giving I started to cry cuz I lost the
giving mode I was just I got into the
business mode and to me like I said
business is a spiritual game if you're
focused on giving if you're doing more
for your client or customer anybody else
you will dominate doesn't matter what
industry you're in and that's what I've
been able to do with you know my 50 plus
companies it really comes down to anyone
can learn anything if it's important
enough to you what makes it important to
me is not just my own life it's like if
I have a problem my shoulder my neck
whatever and I can solve it I know that
there are millions of other people can
be helped by it so it's like my drive is
not just for me that wouldn't be enough
cuz it's easy to meet your own needs
it's not that difficult but if you can
find something that you care about more
than yourself your daughter your son
your family your business your mission
your community whatever it is that's
really the secret to energy and vitality
and strength and really learning and I
think the other thing is um complexity
is the enemy of
execution and one of the things I want
to do with people during this challenge
is take things that seem so complex and
make so simple so you do it if you have
a business and you got this huge complex
plan you hired a giant consulting firm
they put it all together it never gets
implemented you know it you've been in
your companies why because they make it
so complex and it's somebody else's plan
what I really want to do for people at
this challenge is get it really simple
things you can do right now to change
your life you can go to experience it
that day and then you get momentum day
one day two day three day four and all
of a sudden now what used to be hard to
do is easy to do and I think for anyone
you got to understand anyone can learn
anything if you can just break it down
to its simple core and that's what I try
to do most I start with the mind and
emotions and uh to me that's not I don't
tell people to believe uh spiritually or
religiously but I believe prayer is a
very useful thing reminding yourself
you're not the center of the universe
and asking for guidance and help and
other things do that I I personally
believe that but not everybody does and
I don't tell people they have to but it
starts there but there's also when you
have a spiritual side of your life
there's a lot less anxiety because you
believe there's something greater than
yourself and then you do your part like
you said I use I use a similar metaphor
when I say it's you know trus in God and
tie up your camels you thing right but
uh what what most people don't know is
the power of their mind so there's an
entire last two chapters of the book if
no one that reads anything else they say
please read those two chapters because
if you do everything physically well and
you don't manage your mind and emotions
you'll get sick that's really the
essence of it I I used to have all these
fancy things but it's like today I just
I just want to help if I can be helpful
to somebody it gives me tremendous Joy I
might my my hats say you know be a
blessing and you're blessed right that's
what these little hats are I I don't
have a non-religious symbol like a lucky
symbol but it's amazing how lucky you
get when you're working hard to be a
blessing and you know it's amazing what
happens for people so um my life is
already so blessed and and whatever
happens when I'm gone is gone but while
I'm here I want to live fully and I want
to touch as many lives and help as many
people as I can and keep growing myself
when I was growing up I grew up very
poor and I'm the oldest of three and I
had to do all the shopping all the
grocery shopping on my bicycle come home
make the meal and I was happy with all
that but then right when you want wanted
to be done with your work and go watch
sports or do something great I had to
wash the dishes so I swore someday I
will never do the labor washing dishes I
will afford a dishwasher I will find
some way to not have to do dishes I tell
you this a background because when I
told him I couldn't be a Furniture mover
he looks down and goes oh only one other
job left dishwashing now dishwashing in
India is a different labor than you
might picture in your kitchen you're in
this ashram and I report and there's
these Nook solids and yogurts on the
floor and you're standing in your bare
feet and you're taking these filthy
dishes coming across and it's 4 hours a
day for six or seven days I'm telling
you I was so angry I was so mad I was
mad at myself that I was there I was mad
I was and I was washing these dishes and
upset and plus I was a vegan and you
know I didn't like the fact there was
milk on the floor I was judgmental about
everything in the middle of all this
stuff after about an hour of being angry
I got tired of being angry and some part
of me kicked in and goes damn whatever
you do you're the best at it why don't
you be the best damn dishwasher so I
start washing these dishes with a frenzy
I'm like come on guys speed this thing
up and something magical happened the
thing that I thought was most disgusting
and filled with labor and work became
play and I started to laugh at myself
and I thought what an ego jerk you are
to think that you're below washing some
dishes and then I got beyond my ego and
jerk into why not just enjoy whatever
you do and then when you do all of a
sudden it's not work anymore and that
was my great spiritual breakthrough I
eventually did meet with his Guru and
try to straighten him out but um he
didn't think very much of an 18-year-old
kid straighten him out he laughed quite
a bit he did talk to my partners and
said I think you guys should just you
know keep teaching what you're teaching
and Fit for Life went on to be one of
the most successful books in history uh
but I can't claim credit for that I was
a part of that little piece but I will
tell you that if you can get over what
if you can get yourself to love to do
the stuff you hate to do then there's no
limit to the success you can have in
your life if you can take the things
that you're afraid you'd have to do to
succeed in your business or to succeed
in your life or uh to succeed in your
relationship there are things everybody
doesn't want to do and the more focused
you are on how you're not going to do
that the more life seems to bring those
things up for you and makes them
barriers and that's why you're
successful all successful people tend to
focus on the future all people that are
overwhelmed tend to focus on the past
because you can't change it but so you
say the past is past so let it go right
so imagine just for a second somebody's
home they were they're a strong smart
person but they're not feeling strong
and smart because they've been sedentary
they're not using their body and when
you don't use your body you don't have
that kind of energy I don't care who you
are right you're constantly hearing fear
coming at you from all the news that's
around there and so people tend to focus
on What's Missing what they can't
control and they think about the past
and will the future ever be like that
but none of these patterns are going to
help you but you can change all three
you can train yourselves to focus on
what you're grateful for what you have
and you can always build on success
that's what creates momentum you can
train yourself to be able to say Okay if
that was missing that's no problem with
it here's how I'm going to go after it
here's how I I can find the answer if I
don't have the answer and you can train
yourself to enjoy this moment while
you're building your future so those
three decisions alone I could give you a
dozen but I'll give you an example I ask
people sometimes in seminars and I've
got you know 15,000 30,000 people in a
stadium and I'll say how many of you
know someone who takes
antidepressants and they're still
depressed and 90% of the people raiseed
their hand all over the world and so how
could you take anpress and still be
depressed well because all they do is
numb you in fact on the side of the box
it says can create Suicidal Thoughts so
numbing you doesn't deal with a problem
as long as you're constantly focusing on
what you don't have or is missing as
long as you're focus on what you can't
control you're going to find yourself
not having what you want so it's not
that difficult but what people need is
they need to shake it up you can't do
these things just being in your head
sitting here at home in your head
because there's not enough energy the
one factor that changes anybody's life
is energy and that's so that's why I've
done my Live Events and that's why I
started doing digital events I didn't
want to do like a webinar I wanted to do
something was a true event that's why I
built a stadium 20 foot high LED screens
I created Total interact ability so we
have people from 195 countries
participating in real time able to talk
to them connect with them like they are
live event bring them up large have the
impact so I didn't let you know Co stop
me from being able to help and serve
people because people need a new
environment We All Need A New
Perspective without it you're just going
to keep doing the same old stuff and if
you want 2022 to be different than 2021
or 2020 it's not going to come by hoping
it's kind of like coming up with a
vision coming up with a plan building a
few skills so that you stay strong no
matter what they do in the external
environment momentum is everything right
the hardest part in life is creating
momentum so when that all happened you
know I have built something of momentum
over you know 40 years literally at that
point around the world and you know what
do you do all of a sudden when you know
suddenly they say you can't do an event
with more than 10 people and you've got
15,000 people scheduled to take over the
stadium and you know you know what I did
I went we're going to Vegas they're
never going to shut down Vegas right but
then they shut down Vegas I was like I
know I'm going to rent a church a mega
church from a buddy of mine in Houston
15,000 people they're not going to keep
Costco open and shut down the church
they kept Costco open and shut down the
church so I got to the point where like
what do you do and when you think
there's nothing you can do that's when
you can do something when you think I
don't know what to do that's when you
know what to do if you just push
yourself and so I was like I pulled my
team together I saw a guy do like a
webinar with 2 52 in screens and I said
I'll kill myself first I said I got to
create an experience for people they
need it desperately wherever they are in
the world so literally I pulled out a
tape recorders like okay here's what
we're going to do we're going to do 20
foot high LED screens 50 ft wide highest
resolution in the world
67 you know 50° 180° around me around
the back I'm going to call my buddy Eric
ywn and I'm going to see if Zoom we can
expand him from the little thousand to
20,000 or 30,000 I'm going to hire a
firm to create an app so they can shake
it so it sends a signal and you can hear
reality of people clapping because the
more shake it the louder it gets and I I
just started creting the whole thing in
an hour there so when I was done my my
CFO says uh Tony um you know after you
saw all the numbers he was over 20
million bucks by the time we're done
she's like Tony um should we rent some
of this
first and said to him I said listen of
all first of all you can't I said go do
your best not what I'm looking for I
said second of all this is going to be
this way for a while yeah and we're
going to use this to help more people
and then you know when things go back to
normal we get to go do that too I just
did a date of Destiny where I had you
know uh 10,000 people from 97 countries
and then I had 500 people in front of me
because I built a studio so that there's
40 foot high ceiling so I could
literally lift the 20ft screen and so
now I have a hybrid event people don't
want to come personally I'm there people
people that want to be in the middle of
the night in some other country are able
to participate but all that comes from
just taking action and momentum if you
build momentum you can accomplish
anything you've seen it in sports you
see a team that's dominating and then
somebody steals the ball and the
momentum changes yeah your job right now
is to create momentum and that that's
why I'm building this challenge is
basically to say to you let's do a
breakthrough for you right now so you
know it's real let's get you get a real
result let's get you to shift yourself
physically and mentally and emotionally
so you can build that momentum because
it takes so much energy to rock it out
of the atmosphere takes very little to
take it out of the solar system so that
momentum I think is critical so if
you're feeling sad or frustrated Co you
don't know what's happening in the
future and you're uncertain and go like
oh what do I want I don't know because
your mental emotional state is the
single most important ingredient to not
only success but fulfillment and most of
us do not know how to manage it when I
say manage it I'm really talking about
your mind and your emotions right those
are the two things that if you can
Master those because most people try to
Master the outside world and you can't
control the outside world you can
influence it but the one thing you can
control is how you use your mind what
you do with your emotions and if you
think about the quality of your life you
know again look at people who supposedly
have everything and they're miserable I
get those phone calls from the people
that are so quote famous the great
actors the great musicians they won the
Academy Award They just won the gold
medal and they're literally depressed
and the reason is because they thought
getting something would eventually make
them feel a certain way and it does for
this long and then you're off to the
next thing and then well when you work
so hard for something forever like that
it's not there so what I really like
people to understand is that the quality
of your life is the quality of your
emotions if you have a billion dollars
and every day your habitual emotions are
feeling frustrated and stressed and
overwhelmed your life is called
frustrated stressed and overwhelmed if
you have three beautiful children and a
great husband or a wife or boyfriend or
girlfriend and every day you worry your
life is not love your life is worry
doesn't doesn't matter how you have this
beautiful family so think of it emotions
control the quality of our life and we
have habitual emotions that's why you'll
see people who you know they're always
angry about something I'm sure you know
somebody like that or they're always
worried about something if they're not
worried about somebody they know they
worry about something they don't even
know right or you know some people that
are you know think they're funny and
they're not but they have a good time
you know who do you want to hang out
with so learning how to direct your
emotions and emotions create everything
everything you want in your quote
unquote success will be driven by having
certain drives of emotion and you know
think about it emotions create Wars
emotions create peace eventually
emotions are what you get you in a
relationship emotions how we all got
here you know if somebody had sex and
that was driven by emotion so we are
incredibly emotionally unfit today you
know we're fearful about everything it's
nobody's fault it's just culturally
we've been conditioned to get everything
instantly by having it in our fingertips
in our phone or our iPad or our computer
whatever the case may be and so now when
people don't get what they want
immediately I'm sure you've seen
somebody standing on the street corner
and they're banging on their phone like
give it a minute it's going to a
satellite and back you know people today
have zero patience and then that messes
up the next part that's really your life
quality of life is quality of your
emotions but your emotions are magnified
by the quality of your
relationships if you have terrible
relationships it's going to be hard to
stay in a great emotional state and so
what I try to teach people is what do
you do to take control of your mind and
emotions and fundamentally the most
basic thing you got to do especially at
a time like Co is you got to every day
have a couple of simple practices one of
those is every day you got to feed your
mind and when I say feed your mind I
mean consciously seek out something
that's going to give you new insight new
inspiration new way of looking things
because otherwise today the news follows
you right it's in your pocket in the
news people are good people but they're
doing their job what's their job make as
much profit as possible how do you get
the most profit get the most people to
watch I get the most people to watch
Fear if it you know if it if it bleeds
it leads is the phrase they use in
journalism right and we've seen so much
fear built up now that most people have
lost their faith and you can't lose it
fortunately it's just a muscle that
needs to be regained but you have to
fill your mind you have to pursue it
great ideas are not going to interrupt
you they have to be pursued and the good
news is today if you get away from just
the traditional news you can do go to
podcasts like boss babes you can go to
different locations you can get another
perspective and you can feed your mind
but if you don't feed your mind my
original teacher was a guy named Jim Ron
and he used to say Tony I got a question
for it he said what if your worst enemy
puts sugar in your coffee what's going
to happen to you when you drink that
coffee he said you're gonna have sweet
coffee he said you know what if your
family member your friend Your Love by
accident drops one drop of strick N9
what's going to happen when you drink
that coffee he said you're going to be
dead and he goes That's Right life is
sugar and strick nine so watch your
coffee like every day you got to stand
guard at the door of your mind
especially at times like this when
there's so much fear so you feed your
mind and then the second thing you got
to do is the mind and the body work
together meaning fear is physical but so
is courage have you ever been so scared
that you know like you have a hard time
swallowing or you feel like in your gut
you know that kind of fear that's
physical yeah but courage is not that
you're not afraid courage is you're
scared you know wet lless but you're
going to do it anyway right that it's a
muscle and courage comes from doing
something physical so every day you got
to feed your mind and you got to do
something physical to push yourself
beyond what you're normally comfortable
with meaning go for a jog or a run or
walk really fast or go lift some weights
a little more than you're used to
because every time you push yourself to
go beyond what's comfortable you get
more comfortable with a bigger Challenge
and pretty soon what was hard is easy
and it isn't just the weight or the run
is what happens to your mind and
emotions because they work together and
then what you got to do is really you
got to find a great role model and
decide what do I want to go after and
let me have them show me a way show me
the way at least the pattern rather than
me learning by trial and air and then I
got to take action and then ideally I
got to help somebody's worse off than I
am because that'll give me fuel that'll
remind me that my life is there you know
you know I feed you know 100 million
people every single year now but it's
because somebody fed my family when I
was young and it wasn't the food it was
that Thanksgiving somebody showed up
with a surprise and it showed that they
cared so I think if you learn to take
control of your emotions then you can
take control of your entire life but
without that it's just a pipe dream it's
just more New Year's resolutions and
within six or eight weeks you're back to
where you were before you got to every
day feed and strengthen your body and
you got to do something even in the
middle of covid if it's still there even
if lockdown because if you don't take
care of your body it affects your mind
doesn't it I mean think about this what
is it that screws up everybody's life
fear is the number one thing that's
keeps people from doing what's necessary
and anger and rage while it can mobilize
us if it becomes part of your life on a
regular basis it destroys it so how do
you balance that out well fear anger
they're both physical aren't they think
about what do you feel like if you're
really ever been so afraid that your
throat got really dry you feel this
feeling in your gut right that's
physical courage is also physical again
courage does not mean you're not afraid
courage means you're afraid but you do
it anyway right it's a it's a way of
being in your body so one of the things
that I started doing early on is
understanding and those of you who spent
4 days with me you know day and night
cuz we did it it's in your body still
how to change the way you feel instantly
by a radical change in your body and so
I really want to recommend you do
something at least five days a week
first thing when you wake up in the
morning I don't it doesn't have to be an
hour workout even 30 minutes it can be
something as little as five or 10
minutes there is not a day when I wake
up I've shared with some of you this
already first thing I do I go outside if
I'm lucky enough to be at one of my
homes anyway I have homes in different
parts of the world because I've traveled
the world and done this I'm very
fortunate but I have a cold punch I've
installed in everyone 56 degrees am I
home in Sun Valley idah oh I don't have
a cold punch I don't need I walk through
the snow in the winter or in the summer
I walk through the grass and I get in
the river and then the literally the
river is usually about 39 to 42 degrees
to give you an idea every cell in your
body is moved the blood brushes do
everything right and I do it for two
reasons there's never a day I look
forward to doing it I don't go oh I
can't wait to go in there I do it number
one because it transforms your body the
blood the lymph flow is unbelievable
from a health perspective you just go in
for a minute pop out and it's like a
different world right I don't care what
it is or you can take a freezing shower
would be the minimum why you could do
this if you couldn't do this but it's
about changing your body so radically
and it's also about developing a simple
daily discipline it's like I don't
negotiate with myself I tell my brain I
don't go oh wait I'm not ready or let me
let me count to 10 or maybe I'll do it
tomorrow that pattern of thinking is
what destroys most people's lives and
their dreams you can settle for a life
like most people have or you can create
your dreams but to do it you need to be
able to push yourself so you need to
train yourself in little ways or it
could be just going and lifting weights
and you're going to do like 10 minutes
of pushing yourself or a Sprint or
really fast walk anything because when
you get your blood pushing when you push
Beyond what's comfortable it develops
this determination inside you this sense
of will that you will then use
everywhere else I always say if you
discipline yourself in one area your
life you're going to be able to do even
more in other areas you get momentum
momentum is everything so if you train
your mind great but you got to train
your body as well in some way and I
don't care again if it's five or 10
minutes or you really push yourself or a
full-blown workout it's got to get there
because when you do that regularly
you're going to find yourself having a
better mind the mind and body can't be
separated they're completely connected
you work on both of them you're going to
have a different world and you're not
going to be shut down when other people
like oh it can't be done just move I'll
handle it it's a different way of being
isn't it why is identity so important
for us to shape a positive powerful
identity well first of all so everybody
understands what I mean by identity is
we all have a way of identifying
ourselves we have a way of labeling
ourselves so most of us came up with our
labels based on how we behaved but
really smart people can do stupid things
really nice people can be mean mean
people can be nice and so if you judge
yourself too soon in most people's
identity their labels for themselves who
they think they are has been based on
their past and often many years ago and
so they don't update it so the the
metaphor i' give for identity is like
it's your comfort zone it's not your
goals so if you like if you took a
temperature in the room and said 68
degrees is my comfort zone physically
emotionally financially I want more in
my relationship I want more physically
energy wise I want more financially in
my career but this is what I'm used to
and so what happens people stay in their
comfort zone for the most part and then
let's say something happens and you dip
you're a 68 degre or that's your
mentality and you drop down to 62 61 60
somewhere around 60 or 59 the heaters
kick on and go whoa whoa whoa you're 68
degree or what the hell are you doing
we've all experienced that all of a
sudden you go I'm not going to live like
this anymore I'm not going to be in this
relationship I'm not going to be fat
like this boom and you get this drive
and you start to change but what most
people don't understand is it happens on
the upper end too meaning let's say you
got momentum you start crushing it you
start doing even better than you think
you go from 68 to 70 88 you're
98° financially emotionally spiritually
whatever the metaphor is and then what
happens you're goes hey hey hey your
brain goes who the hell do you think you
are you're not a 98 degree here right
get back to 68 and if nothing else the
heater stop you lose your drive and
that'll drift you back and not enough
the air condition can kick on you start
to kind of sabotage yourself till you
get back to your comfort zone so unless
you expand your identity changes
temporary it's like when someone says to
me I stopped smoking it's been 8 days
and I go why you C and I say why you
counting so you can tell people how long
you lasted this time like if I went to
somebody and and I said do you hey you
know leis you want a cigarette you're
not going to say what brand is it you're
go no I'm not a smoker notice how people
I'm not one of those that's not my
identity identity is the strongest force
in the human personality if you look L's
Armstrong who has a mixed identity now
in the culture this is a guy that had to
win and found a way to win so when he
was told he had cancer in his lungs in
his brain and in his testicles and he
rides a bike and he's going to die his
answer was no I'm a champion I find the
way I will find the answer and he did
now unfortunately he bent the rules
around the sport and it kind of ruined
his reputation obviously but that
mentality his identity is why he
survived other people told they have
cancer and they're like it's over they
give up they start arranging their
Affairs and so that psychological
difference is the number one thing I
work with people on Because unless you
expand your identity you're going to
basically keep where you are you might
improve a little or not you might go up
and down a bit but you're going to stay
within a realm if you're going to have
an explosive breakthrough to another
level physically mentally financially
spiritually then we got to not only give
you the tools we got to shift that
internal sense of who you really are and
have you find that you are more than
anything that's ever happened to you
that you can handle whatever shows up
even if it's incredibly scary or
uncomfortable just to entrepreneurs in
general uh and you're an entrepreneur
wildly successful entrepreneur and uh
you work with and are friends with many
many of the top entrepreneurs in the
world what are a few of the common
attributes of the super successful
entrepreneurs that you've seen that
might not be the obvious ones that you
know come to mind well gosh you know uh
I give you one example CU I just talking
to him yesterday Mark benof is a dear
friend of mine and he runs a company
called salesforce.com he founded it Mark
went to my Unleash the Power Within
event about 15 years ago he went to it
three times you know you know
repetitions the mother skill he immersed
himself in it again a pro not going to
do something average comes up to me and
introduces himself and says Tony he
saids you've changed my life I'm working
for Oracle I'm leaving I'm starting this
company salesforce.com we're going to
change the business world I never we're
going to do a hundred million in
business I was teasing me other night
he's going to do 7 billion this year
right and I've been on a 15-year Journey
with them you know what what do they
have in common they have a sense of
something they want to serve greater
than themsel you know the only challenge
sometimes in network marketing and I
think what gives it a bad reputation for
some people is you get people in there
that really act like they're doing it
for something large than themselves but
it really is only them now there's
nothing wrong with you wanting to profit
and be successful but motive does matter
and the most successful entrepreneurs
have a motive that includes them but
they want to do something that's going
to change the world make the world
different it's like you know when you're
trying to meet your own needs you get a
certain level of of insight if you're
trying to meet the needs of a your
family you you get a different level of
insight cuz life supports whatever
supports more of life more people if
you're trying to support your community
different if you're trying to you know
have an impact on the world it's even
larger and I found in network marketing
you find a few missionaries that are
like those other entrepreneurs that
really is their mission they'd honestly
do it for free and you know they want to
make money and they do make money but if
you're only doing it for the money the
unfortunate part is um people sense that
and then they feel like it's just a
transaction as opposed to an experience
of added value there's only one way on
Earth to really become wealthy and that
is do more for others than anybody else
is doing you mention you reach out to
someone you'll text someone you'll send
a voice note or a video message uh or
maybe you're calling them or just saying
hi to them and telling them you're
acknowledging something that they're
doing well that you appreciate I don't
think that many people do this why is
this so important for you personally and
why do you think this would help so many
people get out of themselves M eles and
overcome anxiety and stress if they did
this even a couple of times a week I
know you do this every day but just a
couple texts a week why was this so
valuable for people well number one I
love people so I love to sincere if you
just call someone to make a compliment
and it's not sincere anybody can feel
that I don't do that [__] you know it's
like I I pride myself on finding the
goodness in people or the skill sets in
people and I also know that what is
acknowledged tends to grow so from
standpoint of that I want them to feel
that feeling of being appreciated I want
them to know I see what's happening
behind the camera so to speak you know
it's like that's what matters it's not
how everybody else sees you it's how you
really are and then it also deepens
every relationship you have when you
sincerely acknowledge somebody and you
notice something other people don't
notice and so it deepens the connection
and to me quality of life is a quality
of two things your emotions and your
relationships and you know if my
emotions are terrible my relationships
are going to be terrible but if I have
great emotions and I can extend that out
to help other people then it just makes
me feel more alive so I I do it for me
and them it's it's a virtuous cycle
fundamentally the most basic thing you
got to do especially at a time like
covid is you got to every day have a
couple of simple practices one of those
is every day you got to feed your mind
and when I say feed your mind I mean
consciously seek out something that's
going to give you new insight new
inspiration new way of looking things
because otherwise today the news follows
you right it's in your pocket and the
news people are good people but they're
doing their job what's their job make as
much profit as possible how do you get
the most profit get the most people to
watch I get the most people to watch
Fear if it you know if it if it bleeds
it leads is the phrase they use in
journalism right and we've seen so much
fear built up now that most people have
lost their faith and you can't lose it
fortunately it's just a muscle that
needs to be regained but you have to
fill your mind you have to pursue it
great ideas are not going to interrupt
you they have to be pursued and the good
news is today if you get away from just
the traditional news you can do go to
podcasts like boss babes you can go to
different locations you can get another
perspective and you can feed your mind
but if you don't feed your mind my
original teacher was a guy named Jim Ron
and he used to say Tony I got a question
for it he said what if your worst enemy
put sugar in your coffee what's going to
happen to you when you drink that coffee
he said you're going to have sweet
coffee he said you know what if your
family member your friend Your Love by
accident drops one drop of strick nine
what's going to happen when you drink
that coffee he said you're going to be
dead and he goes That's Right life is
sugar and strick nine so watch your
coffee like every day you got to stand
guard at the door of your mind
especially at times like this when
there's so much
fear one of the things you have to
understand about life is everything
changes and everything ends and that
kind of sounds heavy on the front end
but it's a truth if everything changes
and everything ends number one it should
make you appreciate what you have right
now and then my view is what's next is
always better if I make it so it's my
job to make it so and so I think you
know for me I look at it and say you
know when you said uh genius is a young
man's game I think that's total [__]
um I think passion is the Genesis of
Genius if you got enough passion you're
going to find answers nobody else does
but most people run out of fuel meaning
they get tired they get exhausted they
get burned out they get
uh you know the law of familiarity
they're around something so much they
take it a little bit for granted and
I've managed to see something in myself
that I found in every great leader that
I've ever respected and that is I I I
value intelligence immensely but I know
really smart people can't fight their
way out of a paper bag pragmatically
right I'm sure you do too what I see is
the one common denominator of people
that are successful over a lifetime is
the sustained hunger Hunger is the
number one Factor when I see somebody I
don't give about age they AR en care
with their background is if they're
hungry to improve to change to make
something happen I mean if you look at
Richard Branson he's as hungry today in
his late 60s as he was at 16 years old
in that cryp starting virgin leave look
my buddy Mark benof you know he's like
he's I don't think in his early 50s
right now Mark is more hungry today than
when I knew him 12 14 15 years ago when
he was first coming up with the idea I'm
going to you know he went to one of my
seminars over and over again the upw you
know which one he went like four or five
times and he was sitting in the front
row he's a tall guy introduced himself
and said you've convinced me I'm going
to leave this company I work for as an
employee here and I'm going to go start
this new company called
salesforce.com wow and he says Tony
we're going to do hundred million in
business we're going to change business
now he's doing whatever 30 billion right
know it's but it's because he hasn't
lost the hunger and I think the law of
familiarity is what destroys a
relationship you get around somebody
enough you love them and but you don't
have the same passion same aliveness and
I'm just not willing to settle for a
life without passion and aliveness
that's just like there's so much to
learn there's so much to grow there's so
much to give and I'm I'm wired to grow
and give and I I I think anybody who
gets wired to grow and give is going to
have a really fulfilling life it doesn't
matter what you choose to do you're
going to be alive because you're going
to make progress and because you made
progress you have something to give them
three skills will make you successful no
matter how long you live no matter what
changes in society skill number one it's
the ability to recognize patterns you're
really good at you do it in finance you
do it in business I'm not just blowing
you smoke it's why you're successful
because when you recognize patterns it
allows you to go to the Second Step
which is use them if you recognize
Financial patterns you can do great
things you recognize patterns in
business you can turn around any
business you know that's what I've been
doing I have 105 companies now we do7
billion dollar in business and I have no
business background but I recognize the
patterns and I studied the billionaires
that started with nothing and said what
did they do how did they do it how' they
turn it around so if you can recognize
patterns and if you can use them you got
a great Advantage but then gradually
over time like you know if you go to
play the piano you usually play other
people's music initially and then
there's a point where you come through
now you start creating patterns and when
you start creating patterns that's when
you become a dominant force in business
in life in the marketplace and with your
children or anywhere else give more than
you expect to receive if you are
constantly trying to take care of people
give to people if you're your worst time
of your life you can give to people I
promise you everything change I won't
tell you the whole story bore you with
it right now because I want to do this
real quick for you but you know one of
the most difficult times in my life when
I was completely broke not not even
enough gas in my car trying to figure
out how to survive not able to pay my
rent and I I had own B with the story
but I had an experience where I took the
last $19 I had and I gave it to somebody
who else that needed it and afterwards I
was euphoric it made no sense but it was
the first time my life or you know
people say I got to get Beyond scarcity
you never get Beyond scarcity you got to
start be on scarc you got to declare you
got to take the last seeds you got and
plant them and I remember you know the
next day I got to check for $1,200 which
in those days I could have survived on
for almost a month from somebody that
owed it to me and not paid me for two
years the very next day after I gave
every dime I had and had no idea I was
even going to eat I just it was the
right moment it was the right situation
and I just I did what was right so find
someone who's worse off than you are in
the middle of Co do something for them
and I promise you you'll remember how
great your life is and you'll feel
fulfilled because we all it's not about
us you know what I mean it's like it's
not about me it's about we and the more
you can get connected either people you
love or even strangers and do things not
for brownie points just because it's
right somehow inside your own soul your
own Spirit you remember that problems
are not permanent only your Soul's
permanent and you remember that I'm made
for more than just solving this stupid
little problem it just it lifts the
human spirit I don't believe I'm
everybody's teacher or I've got it all
handled but I've spent 42 years looking
for answers of when I was growing up um
you know they called me a motivator they
called me a guru and I hated those terms
because I'm not better than anybody else
and I thought who's influenced my life
I'm an athlete so coaches did and I was
actually much better athlete than some
of my coaches but they still were
invaluable to me because they saw what I
couldn't see because I was in the forest
I was on the court right they were
outside of it and so that's why I
started to call myself a coach not a
guru and also because I want people to
know it there's nobody broken you don't
need to be fixed you might have some beh
behaviors that don't work you might have
some habits you might have some thinking
habits emotional habits and we're the
only humans the only creatures that
should say on the planet that can think
of thought and get ourselves angry think
a thought and get worried think of
thought and get excited think of thought
and feel grateful think of thought and
be pissed off and most of us just don't
know how to run the show and so what I
try to do that that documentary is a
kind of a 2-hour summary of a sixday
seminar I do uh called Date With Destiny
uh but you get to see somebody who's
suicidal there are many people like in a
room of you know 2 3,000 people there's
always a half dozen people dozen people
are suicidal saw there's a woman there
that was um in this cult down in Brazil
remember her I just saw her it was just
in Brazil just literally a week ago and
that was what 5 years ago that film was
made and she has written a book she's
gotten out of the cult she's got other
people out of the cult she's become a
Healer and she's I'm just really really
proud of her so seeing the change last
cuz most people think if you're going to
change that fast first of all they don't
think it's possible but it is you know
you get upset that fast you get wired
that fast you get conditioned that fast
but to see five and 10 years later the
people's lives are changed it's
important for people to see so they know
that you really can produce change in a
moment that is lasting you're really
talking about the most important Concept
in lasting change
identity we all Define ourselves in
certain ways and most of us defined
ourselves years ago and we haven't done
an update and now you're in an
environment where you're constantly told
how bad it is how terrible it is so that
stimulates the old part of the human
brain the fight ORF flight mechanism the
part of your brain that's always looking
for what's wrong so you can hide from it
you know or you can fight it or you can
freeze and hope it doesn't notice or you
can run from it and so that part of her
brain is never going to make you happy
it's an important part there's no
saber-tooth tiger for us to run from
anymore or fight right not for most
people but now we get that about what
are people saying about me online or you
know or do I have enough money in a
country that even if you have very
little money in America even if you're
in quote unquote a poor environment you
know I I support I provide 100 million
meals a year I'm almost to a billion
meals now I'm at 825 million meals to
give you an idea in the last seven years
so I'm in helping everyone I possibly
can but you got to help them here and
here too you know so I use the food as
the excuse to get into here and here and
start showing people what's possible and
I think we're in a place right now where
a lot of people are in this learned
helplessness and they don't realize you
know if you if if as an identity if
identity is how you've identified
yourself and you see yourself as a
procrastinator why cuz you procrastinate
so many times and disappointed you don't
want to be disappointed so now you're a
procrastinator you're no longer
disappointed you feel certain you'll
never have your goals but you feel
certain that's what most people do in
their life but if you set let's say a
thermostat in this room at 78 degrees
and the temperature drops far enough
something's going to happen because the
computer's going to go hey hey hey
you're a 78 degre or what are you doing
here at 68 and the heaters kick on and
suddenly you get this drive I'm sure
your listeners or viewers have had this
experience many times in life we're
finally This Not Another Day not I'm
changing this relationship I'm losing
this waight I'm going to finally do
something and then you push push push
now some people push push push and they
go beyond their comfort zone beyond what
they expect not their goals it's what
they're used to it's their comfort zone
and let's say that 68 degrees is where
they're used to financially it's not
what they want or their relationship or
spiritually or physically and they grow
to 88 98 99 degrees suddenly the brain
goes hey hey hey what are you doing here
you're you know you're you're not a 99
degree you're and then all of a sudden
the heater stop and you lose your drive
and if that's not about the air
conditioners kick on and you start to
sabotage and you go what happened to my
life so identity is the number one thing
I work to change with people to expand
it not to get rid of it but expand your
own sense of who you really are and what
you're capable of and people think
they're going to get identity by like
people say to me I have no self-esteem I
hate that word so overused and abused I
don't have my self-esteem cuz when I was
growing up my parents said these
terrible things and those terrible
things I said isn't it convenient you
only remember those
things you know they said a million
things but suddenly you've H in on those
but let's get real someone can tell your
whole life you're a piece of crap and
you can say screw you read between the
lines and make your life work someone
tell your whole life you're beautiful
you're intelligent you're the smartest
person in the world and you don't
believe it because self-esteem doesn't
come from what people say about you
self-esteem is earned within yourself
it's esteem for yourself which only
comes by doing things that are
incredibly difficult and then your brain
goes this is who I am the reason I've
done firewalks for years I used to do
skydiving but you know it's hard to get
30,000 people in the middle of the air
above New York middle night but the
reason I did these metaphors was because
when someone does something they once
thought was difficult or impossible and
you get the other side the brain goes if
I can get myself to do this what else
can I get myself to do it changes their
identity when your identity expands your
whole world expands it's about growing
and giving I me know that's overly
simplistic but that's what I want for
her it's like you know it's about laugh
loving growing giving you know and
giving passionately and generously and
graciously it doesn't I don't mean just
money I mean of your presence you know
it's very easy to say hello and not be
there it's very easy to say I love you
and you know it's just a habit you know
about you know depending on which
studies you read about 47 to 52% of
things we do are just habit the cool
thing about habit is it allows you do
other things like you know trying to
drive a stick shift car in the beginning
is way it's overwhelming now it's one
thing I can do 20 other things right but
the problem with it is technology has
made us become more and more habitual
and less and less connected and so from
my daughter I wanted her to experience
love that's what life is to me and when
you are loving you have to grow to keep
loving and you when you're growing and
you're loving you're going to give and
to me if that's all she does if she
learns that life is not what you're here
to get it's what you're here to give
that you're being called to find what
you're called for and I don't know what
you'll be called for she you know May
she might sing she might draw art she
might just be a mom she not just one of
the most important things in life she
might I don't know what she'll do and I
have no frame of reference about how
she's going to do it I have only one
frame of reference she's going to be a
person that's earned it and she going to
be a person who's proud of herself
because the earned part to me is where
the pride comes it's like I have this
amazing life you could take away all the
toys and things that I have you couldn't
change who I become as a man yeah and
and also because I never had those
things and I earned those things there's
there's the the stories and the examples
and you know what it's like right to
conquer all the challenges to get there
I want my daughter to have all those
experiences but to me life is love and
life is growing and giving it's really
that's what the whole game is about as
far as I'm concerned because you made it
this far in a video I want to celebrate
you most people start and don't finish
most people never actually follow
through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you are
different you are special believe Nation
you made here all the way to the end and
I love you so it's a special celebration
if you put a hasht believe down in the
comments Below on this video I will
showcase you and celebrate you somewhere
on the screen in a future video because
you are awesome for some incredible Alex
hosi motivation check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there most people most Champions do not
have something that you do not have they
lack something that you have for a
champion in the Physical Realm a lot of
times it's they don't have an off switch
they just keep going and so to the same
degree